you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body image not a
big home
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're a strange animal
you're getting louder
all right we are live that's the sound
of the weekend coming your way i am your
host steven crowder producing with me in
studio as always is
jared who is not gay you can go to
lighter with credit.com for all
references follow him at not gay jared
on twitter filled on the legal
obligations are we good
i'm gonna call it good for this week
okay we're good everyone draw your own
conclusions we have a lot to get to
today
we have
three great guests mike ward uh who
actually has been put before a human
rights tribunal for telling an offensive
joke in canada he'll be here to talk
about that and i'm going to convert him
this is the world we live in this is the
world we were right this is just real
life in this real life we'll have our
finger at the censorship button ready
gosh um and i'm going to convert him
into a conservative on-air or maybe he's
already a conservative at this point in
quebec there are no conservatives there
are liberals and liberal separatists
then we have lauren southern who is of
course our friend another canadian but
uh she made news because she had she was
attacked by feminists who poured a
bodily fluid on her and they they will
do that they will do that they will do
that that's kind of their calling card
they're the wet bandits i don't know
what bandits and then uh of course we
have courtney uh courtney kirchhoff our
very own she wrote a column this week um
not canadian not canadian not canadian
at all
and uh wrote a column about why you
cannot be a man in 2016 and vote bernie
sanders i wrote one a while back from
the male perspective
and uh she wrote it from the female
perspective so it turned out really
turned out really well so full show for
you but this week obviously a lot has
been going on
ohio is the big talk
yeah what a mess
this whole thing is a mess the whole
thing is just just
just i just feel sick
you know you just get you hit that point
and you're just done
you think it's going to get better you
think oh this could turn around but then
like the reality show takes a new plot
twist and it's like when you're you're
so hungry the election right now for
conservatives you're so hungry
you're so hungry you go to a restaurant
and then nothing looks good on the menu
that's kind of where i've been there
i'm just like uh
okay
all right you know the truth is here's
what's something i just thought about
today i don't know if many people have
realized this this is the first election
i can think of maybe if you go back to
william mckinley or you know someone who
we don't really know about as far as the
elections this is the first election
where both of them could possibly be
rendered and eligible for criminal
activity if it's hillary clinton versus
donald trump hillary clinton right they
just talked about a big witness if the
fbi indicts her on the email server
scandal and donald trump has to appear
in court over the uh the trump
university scandal some respect this
these are america's best
this is the finest we have to offer and
show some respect america's best um
i'm not i mean trump has lost suits
before hillary clinton hasn't so if we
have if we have a president there
hillary clinton will probably win and
there's a stronger chance that trump
could probably lose maybe they both get
through the point is that that's even
looming is is insanity it really isn't
can we just pick people who aren't
criminals to start
that being said i still hate kasich more
i don't know why
i still it would it wouldn't
like sadly from who the heck are you to
arch enemy numbers
who the heck are you two he won ohio no
god
no god please no no
no
no
john kasich won ohio governor of ohio
now let me be clear okay
he's in a state that is over people say
well it's a swing it's not really a
swing state it's a blue-collar union
state where some of them still vote for
handouts and they think a republican
might do better because democrats have
screwed them that's really what it comes
down to let's be honest here if you want
to talk about big influences we've
talked about this big unions they have
far more money than the evil koch
brothers or big oil they give and union
members in the midwest this this bs
about the midwest being america's
heartland it's the handout land
it's well why don't you make a better
car how about you pay me 132 000 in
salary and benefits uh we'll go under
that's okay we'll take a bailout we'll
take a bailout for 500 alex so i'm just
tired of this there is no heartland to
america in the midwest listen i'm i'm
from ohio okay
can't confirm go on i can't confirm it's
just like i'm tired oh we're a working
class listen just because you are
working in a factory doesn't mean you're
more working class than a guy who runs
the factory than a guy who bought it
okay this idea that there's no american
manufacturing is untrue there's plenty
of american manufacturing it's just not
where you want it to be it's just not in
steel anymore it just may not be and
there's still plenty of coal hillary
clinton will of course put you out of
business she promised that we ran that
at the website openly promised to put
coal workers out of business um
so john kasich wins ohio i get it that's
i got off on a tangent better than you
know he was preceded by a
i don't know how left but a democrat for
sure so yeah you'd rather have him there
especially if hillary clinton's
president you don't need to oust this
guy and have a super far leftist in a
swing state like ohio people from under
hillary clinton there too they want him
to stay he won by like 61 reelection
so he he's good for that state
right sure sure for the country not so
much and when he won ohio
confetti was falling and fireworks and
strippers i mean you should this guy it
was like when you win mario kart that
went down in the whole my hometown by
the way of berea did it they know how to
throw a party it sounds like an std it's
a horrible name for a hometown it's also
home of the browns go on so john kasich
wins ohio everyone thinks okay john
kasich you've made your point
right and then he'll bow out he gives
this victory speech like it's even
mathematically possible for him to win
and everyone's watching do you think
he's gone
he's not gone that's the whole point
he's never gone
that's john kasich john kasich is the
guy closing time was a long time ago
closing time
john kasich is the guy at a party
who won't leave
and he was never invited you didn't no
one even wanted john kasich at that
point there was maybe like one person at
the party he's like no no man you just
gotta give kasich a chance he's cool nah
we don't like we don't want john kasich
at the party i told you no man you just
gotta give him a chance and you say no
everyone's like no we don't want him
there but the one guy sneaks him in and
you're like oh
john kasich is here what happened what
happened was that you carl and he's like
yeah but you just got to get to know him
and we've gotten to know him we don't
like him we don't want him ironically
john kasich has unified everybody in
agreeing that he's a douche everyone
agrees that he sucks nobody wants them
and it's not even that they hate him but
here's what bothers me about john kasich
and i was talking about this on on um uh
glenn beck's show today i know hold your
hate mail
i have friends who are liberal too um
john kasich does this whole i'm not
gonna take the low road to the highest
office in the land you know that's his
quote
what
your only path to any kind of victory
is through screwing the voters with a w
with a technicality at the republican
convention there is no more greasy
underhanded low road than that
it's mathematically impossible
he can't win a hundred and twelve
percent of the delegates remaining
i don't know i mean i don't know you
know listen i'm an underdog story rocky
no you're the idiot story
you're i am sam
okay
just get out
well yeah you know it's funny because i
found myself in a group of people like
many who were like thinking ah we just
gotta if only trump can't win both
florida and ohio someone doesn't want
trump who doesn't think he's a good hand
it doesn't really reflect the majority
of republicans out there we don't want
him to win and then as soon as i thought
about that
donna me
tuesday night i'm thinking ah kasich
going ohio
oh crap he's never no idea he's never
going like this he's anyone off the back
really let's be honest rubio and crew
support yeah exactly so i mean there's
no i think if kasich drops out halfway
i'm gonna make it rain with confetti
when i win ohio you think you think the
guy went to the moon with lance bass
it's just unreal this guy thinks it's a
victory
i just it's you know
he's just he's just a greasy he looks
like a looks like a seagull in the bp
oil spill
you know he's got that he's got those
like you know like the kind of down
feathers in the head of a baby bird
someone gave him that hair it's a little
matted
it has like that and you know the mama's
feeding them and he's kind of greasy in
nature and hunchback and he's just like
you know a new one
common car
my god
that's john k that's how i picture him i
just and i don't i don't you know listen
i don't wish death upon anybody and
certainly not john kasich but i can't
say that like i can't say when it
happened when he was showing that that
that the
it crossed my mind not like i want it i
would never wish death upon anybody but
a part of me was hoping like well maybe
that confetti could just be anthrax just
a little bit you know
because it would be self-inflicted and
who am i as a libertarian if he wanted
to throw anthrax on himself who am i to
tell him that he can't do that that's
his body that's this is this prerogative
so that's john kasich right now and i
just i don't know anyone who really
wants i don't honestly i don't dislike
kasich i'm just frustrated with this
whole thing and like we said i'm not a
trump guy people know that and i know
everyone gets so upset but
if the gop
if through like a contested convention i
can kind of understand if they get there
and trump only has you know 40 45 of the
vote and the total other delegates with
everyone else is more if he doesn't have
a majority of the delegates i understand
okay putting it in head to head and and
seeing how it turns out because trump
loses in a head-to-head to anybody right
there is a problem there's a system in
place if trump you don't want someone
getting
a nomination with only 30 percent
you know average in states that's a
problem but and i've said this
if trump wins the delegates outright it
has to be trump
it has to be and if he doesn't and they
trot out kasich
or romney or paul ryan like we're
hearing
at that point i will relieve myself on
the ashes of the gop okay so trump
supporters who get met appreciate that
consistency
we'll be like the feminists with with
lauren southern
we putting out that fire
with bodily fluids because i do not want
to see
that kind of a screw job like you see
with the democratic party yeah yeah and
that's what john kasich is hoping for
and that really really bothers me like
it's one thing if you you know if it
were ted cruz and donald trump they're
neck and neck and it goes to convention
and then okay i understand but that's
not it john kasich has no mathematical
chance to this is when people talk about
career politicians you want to talk
about establishment let's talk about
john boehner let's talk about mitch
mcconnell let's talk about john kasich
these are people who are almost lifetime
politicians who have clearly betrayed
their voting constituency but let's
define establishment
it's their picture right next to the
dictionary we'll come back
i'll i'll clear my head and we'll fight
about something else
in fact it was a little bit frightening
but they fought with expert timing
this is breaking news on laura with
crowler i'm perry mallison we take you
now to a republican party currently
underway
yeah so i met this girl and she did she
interned for oh really yeah yeah at the
network and she is an absolute monster
yeah i've heard bad things is that
is that casey
he's coming over he's coming
hey guys what a great party you're doing
a great job here uh with the republican
party i brought a case of zima if
anybody wants someone so she would bring
the image on kasich you know who drank a
lot of zima was my father who was a
mailman before i was governor of ohio
did anybody even invite him nobody ever
invites him and boy i tell you what he
sure liked to party as well
he had quite the reputation around the
mail office we'll keep you updated as
the republican party progresses after
this
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s
crowder where i'm tweeting all day long
i'm ticking off the social justice
warriors you should see the amount of
hate i get on there far far far worse
than any fat sports illustrated model or
black lives matter charlatan so listen
it's free you get to be entertained and
you can chime in also if you're
following me on twitter you can send me
your tweets and maybe you'll be lucky
enough and i mean lucky enough because i
have a lot of followers okay that they
call me the follower machine to have
your tweet to me or not gay jared
included in our rockinest tweet of the
week so follow me on twitter at s
crowder if not
i don't want to say i have sights on
your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
all right we are back some people get
mad at the dancer like
you're corny
screw you so we're back people listening
i have no idea of course the live video
stream is at lottery with crowder.com
for those listening terrestrially on our
wonderful affiliates in of course wham
beautiful home station detroit alaska
new hampshire florida
uh
some places
some others missouri i don't know a few
few stations
it's a good problem to have though
because you're losing track that's a
good problem to have i'm losing you
should be like you know a couple and now
you know it's growing yeah i don't care
anymore listen if people want to carry
the show they carry the show that's one
thing jared knows because not gay jared
started when the show was nowhere and
people leave this indicator they don't
we're not making
half the time like when i get called to
speak at schools by the way next week
tuesday uh in washington dc let me bring
this up here i have a live show
you know i don't advertise these a lot
anymore because people show up to
protest and it's not as fun american
university
in washington dc so black lives matter
get your fat checking ready and you can
get mad at my jokes gonna make fun of
aids and black people so get ready
sometimes two at the same time so
speaking of which we had that ethnic
introduction and we just talked about
aids and black people um you
someone just tweeted oh no god no god no
not john kasich this you know he is
unified every nobody wants him and the
funny thing is it's not like anybody
hates him he's just just just just
ah he's only only people like him are
the people that are so
far apathetic right beyonce safe with
the whole thing he's a safe kind of like
not funny haha funny queer well that too
that too but he's safe kind of if you
want to seem as though you're above the
fray oh you know i kind of like kasich
and then you you want to confuse a
kasich fan and say oh okay why
um so i want to talk about something
interesting jared made a great point it
ties into an article at lotto with
crowder.com this week where uh a black
social justice warrior at buzzfeed
dressed nicely and dressed poorly as a
social experiment to prove racism
microaggressions and he proved the exact
opposite of that
it's so funny
the best part to me is that buzzfeed
still was like
a thousand bucks
gotta gotta run with it yeah see what
just got thrown out there well the epic
was happening conclusion was when he
dressed nicely people treated him better
he you know he was missing change in the
bus they said that's fine the lady at
the dry cleaners or the grocery store
said oh was you looking great today and
people weren't eyeing and he's like when
i dressed like a thug people were you
know it just shows how i'm going home a
second isn't that wonderful mr black i
don't remember his name for all intents
and purposes he's mr black mr black
isn't that wonderful that you put on a
blazer and some khakis
and you're treated just like the white
guy here's the thing if they hated you
because you were black
the skinny tie mod squad suit wouldn't
fake them out
right it's not like a t-rex where it's
like based on movement like racists they
only see you if you're
in sweatpants
they know you're black
they just know that you're dressing
nicely same thing for me if i wear
sweatpants into
i don't know banana republic which which
is why i don't go to banana i'll wear
sweatpants i don't go to bed republic
it's offensive to them and it's
offensive to me being there because i
feel great shame
so this is what he wrote about like like
robert byrd or david duke they don't
have an exception for pleated pants okay
they hate you because you're black
so this article went out and everyone's
like oh how racist this is and so we
wrote an article courtney and i
um
on on how this proved the exact op exact
opposite it went viral because
everyone's going of course of course
that's true and you made a point because
we went to the bernie rally we did that
video which unlike huffpo by the way who
wrote a hit piece on a trump rally with
no substantiation we video recorded the
bernie rally we can prove it
and bernie's up there right he's going
you know one in four african-americans
are well how do we do one in four
african-americans are in prison
you know you're more likely to end up in
jail and graduate high school so he's
giving all of these stats you were
talking about this how the left can give
all of these negative stats on black
americans yeah one of four goes to
prison one in four you know leaves their
child and which are not untrue
leftists we understand there's a there's
a big problem a cultural problem a
fatherless problem a multiple problem
they attribute it to race go ahead
but i'm just i was thinking the day
after the days of reading that article
piecing it together thinking you just
told me one in four black people
men
age 18 to 24 or whatever goes to jail
and then you yell at me when i profile a
black woman a black man thinking i have
a 25 chance of getting murdered or
mugged right here it's a trap
exactly i can't win i can't win now you
probably wouldn't profile that black guy
if he's dressed like the buzzfeed guy in
a jacket pants but if you want i do now
because i heard the stats because he
heard the stuff stats didn't say
anything about justice if it was true
though if you leave
a a democrat convention
if you leave a bernie sanders rally
you're probably going to be more racist
because all you hear about these men in
prison black men in prison all of these
drug trafficking offenses
violent crime right now a big problem
the biggest indicator
of of whether you are successful or not
in life that we have currently available
okay in the united states whether you're
successful not whether you commit a
crime or not whether you're up in jail
whether you finish high school or they
get a college degree whether you start a
business whether you make you know
whether you make a living wage is you
have mommy and daddy and her mommy and
daddy still married
more importance placed on the daddy
people don't like to hear that but a
father in the house
is the biggest indicator that we
have um
it's the constant across all of those
and that's a big problem in the black
community unfortunately people who speak
out like bill cosby larry elder's talked
about that but bill cosby's not a great
ambassador anymore
but leftists just say black boom
statement
and yeah i think it creates more racism
it would have to
i mean the whole thing has look at where
we are now
after barack obama like you said i think
a lot of people with the trump thing
just feel like they've been crapped on
for seven years including white people
who voted for barack obama and then they
say they want their obamas what they
want they want their their hero their
champion the one who says screw you to
the other side
you know executive order executive order
they want their own right version of
that which is which is bad too which is
bad too that's how you know give unto us
a king right that's the famous the
famous story from the bible
because it's not real i know we're going
to get atheists libertarians that's not
the point think of it as an aesop fable
just think of it as tortoise in the hair
but with jesus uh although i don't i
think it's old where give unto us a king
which book is that
you've got me i've got yeah i can't
quote verses two corinthians will say
but it is true it's a great point that
you made they give you all of these
horrifying statistics and then want you
to shut off your evolutionary mechanism
uh of
generalization
which is made for self-preservation
right oh giant bright red colors in the
wild and that frog probably a po you
could probably make a dart out of that
thing you know i imagine being like a
detective these days and
can you describe them pressure
black hair
eyes brown
um
olive
toned you know so anyway we'll expand on
that more afterward how long do we have
until we have to bring in mine ten
seconds okay mike ward is that sure mike
ward after the break here talking about
free speech in canada don't miss it
hey listeners this is jesse former
governor of minnesota ventura here the
bot this week you've had the wolf pulled
over your eyes by the establishment
hacks or trying to rape the american
voter from their constitutional right to
vote
what they're planning on doing is
borderline treasonous not borderline it
is treasonous because word on the street
that uncle jesse has heard regarding the
facts of a brokered convention
is that they're gonna try and trot out
paul ryan
paul ryan on a general election stage
versus hillary clinton
because two vaginas are better than one
know the facts
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ar-15.com oh there's another one the
boom you got them yeah thank god for
ar15.com they have ar15 and accessories
for sale and the best advice there is on
the web oh no there's another one
you got him yeah with your what ar-15
from where
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to stop
to you
all right i'm glad to bring on our first
guest of the program so
many of you listening in listen to the
united states don't know about this guy
but i grew up on him so growing up in
french canada um
there's a lot of controversy actually
it's a big issue freedom of speech and
comedy he'll talk about that but he has
an album pedophile jokes and death
threats
in case you were wondering what you were
in for and you can follow him on twitter
at mike ward ca mike ward thanks for
being here brother hey steve thanks for
having me it's rare that i get someone
we've talked about that there are a few
people who we get on where it's it's
bizarre for me because it's a celebrity
and you know i always watched you and
patrick grew when i was growing up and
louis jose on music plus and back then
though you didn't do any anything in
english so that happened since i've left
montreal did you always speak english or
did you learn it to expand your your
comedy no i grew up i grew up
my dad's english my mom's was french
he's dead now but uh and um no no
problem you didn't kill him uh but uh
yeah so i i just grew up mostly in
english and uh i french comedy i
was easier since there aren't as many
comics so it's it's kind of easy to
become famous
and uh
and i was lazy so i was i was just a
french comic and then started doing
shows in like 2007. well i always
wondered too with french comedy um like
where do you go i mean you have montreal
quebec city
what where else is the tour is it like
victoriaville where do you go
what's really weird it's like my last
tour i sold 135 000 tickets and i toured
for like three years just in quebec like
there's a a really big market for such a
little place yeah and it influences to
the stand up for americans
my stand up wasn't really joke telling
and french canadians but it's much more
kind of one-man show you know they bring
in a lot of elements so um it had a big
influence on what i did uh up there i
saw you know comedy works it was i think
2005 or six
and uh man montreal is just a hotbed for
great comics okay speaking of which
we'll get back to that but you explain
for people who don't know
you have been put before a human rights
tribunal basically
your comedy career is in the hands of
the courts
tell everyone how we got to there okay
uh there was a little kid in uh in
quebec who was uh he was famous there
was a tv show um that um it was called
daniel
and
it was like pay it forward and this was
a little kid that was sick he was deaf
and his dream was to sing for the
montreal canadiens the national anthem
so they they put him on that show he
sang for the canadians got tons of media
exposure and then he sang for the pope i
i don't know if his family wrote the
pope or
how he got that gay he sang for the pope
what did he sing for the pope he's not
singing the national anthem is he no he
was singing some you know weird little
christian song uh like uh
i i i
have no idea what he was saying but he
so
and then i just did a joke like five
years later that he wasn't dead yet
because i thought he was like uh you
know a make-a-wish kid that was dying
right now i did that in my show uh in
front of you know
uh adults that had paid
well yeah that's kind of key you would
assume but yeah but uh and then his
family found out they called the human
rights uh commission
and then uh i got a letter saying i owed
80 000 to the kids family for that joke
so uh did you pay it
no no no we i i hired the the best
lawyer i i could get and it cost me more
in legal fees than than what you know
right now i've given a little over 80
grand to my lawyer just to not pay
well yeah in principle now what were the
consequences if you didn't pay was it
going they might ban you from from
comedy what what were the kind of
conditions i i had no idea they just
wanted money like they uh and and and
then in
what was weird during the whole trial
they they at first it was uh they were
talking okay in his joke he said that
the the little kid
didn't die and and uh that i i said that
he was unkillable and i tried to kill
him and it didn't work and
uh and then they started talking like
i'd actually tried to kill the little
kid they're like and then mike ward said
he was going to drown him and and i was
like okay i'm on trial for drowning a
little kid
in a joke it's crazy right
well we did that once we had a lot of
complaints where we were just talk we
were just talking on the program and we
were talking about charlie brown and how
bizarre it was that he lost his hair so
early and either i don't know it was
jared but we said well a little known
fact charlie brown had progeria
and people got really mad well my friend
has project and everyone's always okay
if you make fun of everything until it's
their thing yeah yeah exactly so how did
so this happened they complained and was
this a court that said okay you have a
case and just ordered you to pay the
fine what was that process like yeah i i
got it i got a letter from the human
rights people saying i owe the money so
i i brought this to my lawyer who are
the human rights people like what kind
of commission or court is this
uh it's it's just a bunch of ladies in a
in an apartment i think like it's just
like is it a canadian thing is it
international
it's uh this only exists in canada and
there's a real human rights tribunal in
in the hague in in holland where they go
after like uh you know uh criminal of
like a war for war crimes and you know
gators but in in canada each province
has their own little system and uh it's
not legal like they they send me a
letter saying i owed 80 000. but uh when
i said no they're like okay we're gonna
take you to court and that's why we're
in court now so you're still in court
yeah well the trial is over but what's
really weird uh i thought when the trial
was over i'd get a decision from the
judge but uh i'm gonna get the answer in
like three to six months
well everything takes a little bit
longer in canada your health care i mean
even the court process they have to put
on their powdered wigs
did you did they do that when you did
this
they didn't have the padded wigs but my
lawyer had sort of a suit like he he had
the bottom part you know right yeah yeah
well they must have loosened that
because it was law you had to do the
full english court system for a while
did you know that not kj no i didn't i
know that yeah you'd have judges
fantastic be like a traffic ticket and
you'd go in you'd have some guy looking
like george washington with uh you know
looking like a white captain hook i
don't want to say his incentive to go to
court but that's that's up there on my
list my god i'm gonna speed five over
just so i can have my day in court yes
um okay mike so so this is this is a lot
of americans aren't going to believe
this we've written about this at the
website lotto with crowder
let me kind of tell you obviously
this is a more political cultural show
i'm to the right of attila the hun you
know when i grew up in canada people
thought it was shtick
that i was right-wing um i remember
having a discussion i think was with
deanne smith when i was started talking
about freedom of speech and how
important it was and she said well you
know except for hate speech and she
couldn't believe it when i said that's
not a real thing stop saying that that's
not a real thing
um americans don't appreciate that
freedom of speech is actually very
uniquely amer it's not protected in a
lot of other countries so has this made
you rethink some of that and go oh my
god i didn't realize how little rights i
had in this area
i always thought because you know like
uh growing up i i just figured i had the
same freedom of speeches in the states
because uh canadians never really think
about that or never really talk about
freedom of speech right so like that
when the first
time someone told me okay uh
you owe money for this i was like that's
crazy he he was like on television i
just made fun of him that's like making
fun of uh justin bieber it's like making
fun of you know donald trump yeah and
even yeah and but uh
it's weird it's weird it's made me like
uh hate my country especially
like i like i was i i'm i was never like
i hate canada and i hate quebec even
more and if if
if you guys please invade us i would
like america to invade
make canada it's [ __ ]
it's funny because i've talked about
this when i grew up you know here's the
thing people don't understand you know
this in canada there is no conservative
quebec there's no conservative there's
no libertarian there's liberal and then
liberal separatists you know that's
really the choices you have and so
people hear the word conservative and
they think it's a bunch of you know old
christians they don't understand what
the constitution is about and um i
always say i used to have these
canadians in college professors in the
united states evil empire and i looked
at them i said listen the fact that you
are canada and not the 51st state is
proof that that's not the case you have
this giant land rich in natural
resources with virtually no national
defense whatsoever when compared to
united states there's nothing you could
do and they engage in fair trade with
you guys like they're clearly not an
empire and it's just it's one of those
things where canadians i don't like you
i don't think they think about it a lot
people thought i was joking when i said
hate speech isn't a thing
it doesn't they're like what do i hate
crimes i said murder doesn't need a
footnote if you kill somebody that's
already crime
so it's it's um it seems like there's a
real wake up do you feel like this is in
the comedy community is this happening
or are you in the minority in canada
still i think no i think comics are
really starting to be afraid because
people are like uh just um
this week with the uh angli
talking about how the oh the oscars the
oscars who
well sorry about that who cares like
seriously who cares about
that that's one thing that always freaks
me out people go jokes hurt but the the
only way a joke can hurt you is if your
life has been too easy because if if you
were kidnapped and you know beaten and
you you wouldn't you know escape and go
oh the most the the most hurtful part
was when he made fun of me yeah it was
the fact that he he didn't really i
don't think he recognized my triggers
was upsetting yeah um
it's funny that you say i
i hope that's the case but there needs
to be a cultural shift in mindset and
now you've got you know pierre trudeau
who is mr cracking down an offensive
speech who is mr identity politics i
mean i remember literally i was
accommodating me yeah i'm sorry but did
i say pierre
yeah yeah yeah oh okay we met pierre one
time walking through montreal and he was
giving someone the finger um
well that's another thing in canada i
was like this guy has no security i mean
i couldn't imagine
like canadians they don't try and
assassinate their prime ministers their
prime ministers literally get pies in
the face like an acme cartoon yeah
and americans it's so silly um
i remember i was there in con so comedy
works one night and it was when harper
was elected i think when he was first
elected was that 2005 2006 or was that
re-election okay yeah uh i think first
time it was like 2004 or five or
something okay let's see okay well i was
there that night now david pride was
there david acker uh david uh uh derek
ling venus was there mike mayo was a
friend of mine and there's a bunch of
people just kind of an open mic you know
jimbo's pub and there are people going
up there and everyone just had their
jokes about how much they hated stephen
harper and how they were so liberal
and i remember it was just assumed this
is default right we all agree on this
and i remember thinking you're just
you're destroying your own ability to
make a living because
you know we understood that's the end
game we've been aware of this on the
right for a long time you know
universities banning ann coulter i think
milo yiannopoulos
it's very very i was kicked out of a
school um
i don't remember if it was marianopoulos
or if it was uh it was a vanier one of
those you know those those sage ups uh
because i made a muhammad joke during
their cultural
fair week and they said you're not
allowed to you're not allowed to come
back
and uh i was amazed that comedians were
supporting this platform so yeah
how what do you think it takes is your
case getting a lot of press there and
other comedians taking note do you think
like really or do you think they're
still going to go in and pull the lever
for people who are going to support this
crap i think if if i win it'll be like
nothing happened and if i lose it's
going to scare a lot of people the thing
i have been happy about though is people
uh even people on the left have been
supportive and generally free speech is
just uh people on the left
they think more of the people's feelings
than they do about you know actual our
our rights and the way you know
that we should be allowed to say what we
actually think and not just pretend uh
everyone liked each other right but um
now a lot of comics that are to the left
have been really supportive because they
realize that like
if uh if they get rid of me then whoever
is second most offensive to whoever you
know is the judge right they'll go after
him next and then the yeah so you can
never get rid of everyone right well by
god they can try okay mike ward see we
have to go to a break we want to bring
you back and talk about this more
hopefully fix that microphone not get
jared what are you doing mike ward ca on
twitter
lotto with crowder free speech stay
tuned
this is breaking news on louder with
crowder i'm perry matheson we take you
now to a republican party currently
underway hey you know what's a really
fun dance is the macarena i tell you i
really get a kick out of it why is he
still here you know because it's a dance
but it's also exercise and we have an
obesity problem in america particularly
ohio he's always here no one invites me
always shows up an exercise is important
if you want to get a job where i tell
you
you'll be witted by the end of the day
my father was a mailman holy [ __ ] we'll
keep you updated as the republican party
progresses after this
loser in his her or z's mother's
basement watching this on the youtube
live stream listen youtube is great but
it's not always super convenient if
you're on the go that's why this show
which is actually syndicated as a radio
show is available on itunes soundcloud
or any kind of podcatcher that you
android users for free just search lotto
with crowder find it subscribe you get
the full show and some exclusive content
that you actually won't hear
on youtube including giveaways extra
commercials me
beating not gay jerry within an inch of
his life but it's okay he always comes
back into work so i can fire him so
itunes soundcloud or podcatcher get the
full show and listen to louder with
crowder on the go if you don't you're
probably a racist rapist
all right we're back and i know that the
guest knows why that song is significant
you can follow him on twitter at mike
ward ca mike you know what that's about
yeah that's a gown i used to do a show
called the legro show uh that i was i
was like um sort of a guy that was
really loved the 80s
and uh that's a lot of hair bands
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly everyone
like like yours
actually exists yeah it's my uncle remo
masi zhang
is actually
and
combined and people don't like these are
real people
but that was actually where i first
heard that song watching the show and we
ended up incorporating it into the bumps
um
so it's just uh it's funny i was i was
raised on it and i had no idea that we'd
be here now one thing that was really
sort of stuck out at me mike
before the break you said yeah you know
the left
they don't really understand this sort
of concept of rights that is language
that when i grew up in canada so i grew
up from 3 to 18 left at 18
no one would have understood or even
used the paradigm of sort of the left
and rights and authoritarianism
so it's surprising to me to hear you say
that because no one ever spoke like that
yeah is that just you
sort of with your own i guess awakening
i think yeah having the government bring
me to court
i'll do it that's a good wake-up call
now
we we've started to get sort of uh i'm
from quebec city and for some reason
quebec city is like one of the only uh
right-wing cities in uh eastern canada
really i think that's why yeah there's a
i guess the separatism could kind of the
idea of sovereignty a little bit could
lend itself toward independence maybe i
don't know
most of the right though in quebec are
anti-separatists
yeah sorry about that
no idea um so okay i just see i didn't
know that i had no idea i mean you meet
a lot of canadians and we would talk
with them my aunt just died so my mom
was back up there and they'd talk with
um family like legreemon and eric and
talk about things and they'd go like oh
yeah that's it that's it i don't know
darren i never thought of it like that
you know yeah and they're they just they
haven't thought of these things like
they hadn't thought of free speech they
hadn't thought of well why do you have
the second amendment in the united
states big reason is to protect the
first amendment you know um if they can
see for eighty thousand dollars it's not
unheard of for them to simply storm your
house and take you to prison for doing
something um yeah they just a lot of
them just they just don't think of it
that way so it's so surprising to me to
see you i guess sort of the term is
taking the red pill did it take the
court to make this happen or were you
sort of shifting before that
uh no no i've been uh
no i've i've always been sort of uh
right leaning i'm not i'm i'm
i'm right leaning for uh quebec which
means like i'm about as you know liberal
as bernie sanders basically but i'm
forced free speech right and uh no for a
lot of things i'm i'm for small
government i hate having the government
tell me you know how even like uh i mean
like city got municipal government
telling me okay my
my hedge has to be this height and you
know i'm like yeah you know it's my land
let me do what i want yeah no not in
quebec um that's not really the mindset
there it's funny i was you mentioned the
academy awards so this is one too where
i got a lot of complaints at
marianopolis college because i made a
bunch of asian jokes because as you know
marianapolis is entirely asian and
jewish
and um
i've always had a clean show but pretty
politically incorrect
so a surprise that people get really
offended you know they would have joey
elias before and you know where how he
can get and then he's clean but i'm the
one who gets the complaints because he
made fun of asians um i made fun of
muslims
the bit that got me into the just for
laughs uh the year i did it was and i've
told this before but you would
understand it more um you were i think
maybe just doing french comedy at this
point because i didn't cross paths i i
talked remember the band sam
yeah yeah
rapper yeah rap group sorry and there
were a lot of them and uh um i remember
doing a bit where i was talking about
you know you have these french canadians
now they're using vid using words
they've seen in rap videos i don't even
grasp the meaning and the bit was jared
you're gonna have to edit this because
then it's american but you'll get it i
said you know no no
and people were like
shock and laugh because everyone had
heard a french canadian use that the
n-word because they heard it like you
hear
or only all the time like they would be
french and there would be the f word and
the n word were the only english words
and um
a lot of complaints and people were like
you know we get the most complaints from
the stuff you do even though
it's not dirty and i just thought this
is such a weird time
and i had to leave there with my hair on
fire and it sounds like you're about
there
yeah yeah exactly i gotta i'm married
right now but i i gotta get a divorce
and find an american don't put up with
me there's an american woman that wants
to marry a dude that kind of likes looks
like a lesbian i'm i'm available
is your wife french
my wife is french yeah oh okay so and
she do you speak french more
uh yeah i speak french with my wife uh
and she uses what's weird like we we
have a house in florida whenever we go
to florida she's so used to using the f
word she'll like use it you know in
front of little kids and i'll have to
tell her yeah you know don't don't say
that at disney world right well yeah
it's it's a verb in french people don't
understand it's not doesn't mean the f
word it can mean like something it can
actually mean like oh something's broken
yeah yeah this is a and you add a and
that this is weird and yeah
and and the way they cuss too well well
not gay jared with the jean guido he was
like it's just so weird i was like well
a lot of canadians even the english
canadians they add their cuss word at
the end of the sentence because that's
how it's structured in french yeah yeah
so it's funny man florida remember how
offended quebec got when there was uh
the florida newspaper that said
something french canadian comes this way
was a headline and it was a guy in a
speedo you remember that it was like
national outrage and they banned they
banned triumph the insult dog
yeah i remember as a kid i was in high
school i was at this point i wasn't i
was going like
of course that's not right you're
banning an insult dog it's they're just
so sensitive
um do you see that shifting not only in
comedy across the province or do you
just kind of think it's gone
no quebec is really sensitive quebec is
really really sensitive and i think
canada is sensitive but
quebec's the worst for that
and you don't see it getting better
i don't i don't see it getting better i
i think and i think it's getting worse
everywhere i think it's getting worse in
the states i think uh
you know
something's gonna have to happen for for
like
everyone to sort of wake up and go okay
i don't i don't want to live like this
that you know i'm always i'm always
careful okay i can't say this i can't
say we have to go to a break we're
watching we can do a web extended here
for an extra couple of minutes but uh
lottery with credit.com mike ward ca on
twitter
thank you mike everybody else stay tuned
we'll be
takes back time
and now it's time for your dating advice
minute
with bill cosby
now this letter comes to me
from mr jay
that disclosed first name kassick from
ohio in the united states
he says mr cosby
i have a problem with my lady who
doesn't want to do ripping the baby
because
i do have a hemorrhoid problem which
defines to be off putting into them
okay mr catholic i understand where
you're coming from
there was a time
you see
when mr carter himself was battled with
the eighth demon
and it is a battle that i tell you can't
be one but it is not without casualties
especially in the boudoir
so what you need to do is sit down with
your wife and have a talk about your
personal problems
and when you're having to talk with a
little woman
you're gonna offer her some coffee
but in the car there's gonna be some
drugs
that's very important that you put some
drugs in the coffee after about 15
minutes she's not gonna have a problem
with the hemorrhoids and you'll be doing
the hip hop below the homies
this has been your dating advice minute
with bill cosby
you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body image not a
big home improvement
marketing we are definitely going to get
letters you're listening to talk radio's
strangest animal
you're a strange animal
you're getting louder with crowder
all right we are back in the second hour
producing with me in studio as always is
jared who is not gay follow him
at not gay jared of course if you're
listening to this live
uh you know you could just be in the
middle of a stupor from st patrick's day
looks like sean hannity has an exclusive
with donald trump in arizona on saturday
well there's that so this is breaking so
there you go there's that there you go
there's been a while it's been at least
a couple days since i've seen one of
them on the tv so
i need to get i mean whatever you think
about donald uh trump the guy knows how
to play the media pretty easily
yeah
you know it's the whole there is no such
thing as bad press and i think he knows
that and he kind of plays off this idea
that
yeah even if he's even if they're
screaming for being a racist it's still
free advertisement name reaction that
he's going to gain from it that's the
kind of thing that makes me want to
support trump just because everyone says
oh you're racist you like huffpo
i know they call someone that so many
times like all right okay you know what
let's go with that i always want to walk
people down the trail when they say
you know they're anti donald trump i'm
like oh do you really know why you're
anti-donald trump or did you just
memorize a few hufflepuff lines and they
start going down these lines of these
these huffpo headlines i'm like
i really don't force me to defend him
now i don't think donald trump is a
racist now do i think david duke is a
racist yeah do i think some people who
endorsed him do i think the guy who
sucker punched the block at the rally as
a racist
there's a strong chance by the way my
my asian friend met derek the other day
really yeah
did you hit on him
no he said the race i asked him how bad
the gaydar was going off he said not as
bad as the racism dar that's not a very
catchy word we need to come up with
something better but he said because
he's running for mayor and my friend
works with like yeah he's running for
mayor of baltimore and my friend kind of
works with some people that kind of do
that and he's
first of all i'm a friend
a good friend of mine he's not very tall
he's an asian guy and he's like you
don't need to specify you no need to
kick a guy while he's down he's asian
he's a no he's asian he's he's got tough
but he's always aging he's like you know
five four four five i'm not sure i'll
tell you matter of fact but right barely
taller than him one second if you meet a
tall asian
it requires a follow-up question
that's how abnormal it is this is true
think about it if you meet a guy who's
six foot who's eight like really looks
asian and he's six foot one
you're almost oh so
where where are your parents from like
japan okay and if it's one like china
you're sitting there in your head you're
only thinking all right how can i ask
about this without
getting in trouble
so pituitary tumor well what's going on
here gigantis
gigantism i don't know i don't know but
yeah he met him the other day which is
pretty funny so he's really tiny to ray
you can fit him in your you can fit him
in your back pocket in your black pocket
in your black
[ __ ]
i think we should call it a show we
should just call it just wrap it up
uh for those listening terrestrially you
may not be aware deray is a very
influential black lives matter activist
this is the problem too with with what
we do you know
obviously we're incredibly grateful to
everyone here watching live stream on
youtube or the soundcloud itunes
livewiscrider.com we're also syndicated
terrestrially where people are older and
we're grateful we still of course want
to be uh talking to all of you but there
really is a disconnect
where the older folks are just not aware
what's going on with you they go deray
listen deray is way more important than
al sharpton or jesse jackson oh yeah and
they just have no clue they don't
understand there's a whole new
uh a whole new generation of social
justice race-baiting hacks who've come
up online you know al sharpton has been
seen as a joke by people of our
generation ever since he appeared in
little nicky no one takes they're
serious there's only a few people who
beyonce you know it's beyonce millions
and millions of followers on twitter and
there's only a few people she follows
maybe eight deray is one of them the
wraith yeah that's kind of like his you
know part of his clinton
eliza minelli for black gays
that's true and they gave a lot of money
to to to ferguson
right felons and such i just can't
imagine deray not being a fan of beyonce
or king b as the gays call her king
queen bee queen bee queen queen b what
did i say king bs i said king b that's
crazy well
jury's still out
i've seen those pictures without makeup
hey speaking of racism
we're at that point where everyone who
was once declared racist against barack
obama is now sexist because of hillary
clinton i don't know if you heard about
this this week there was a lot of
backlash because when hillary clinton
gave her victory speeches in ohio and
florida
uh a few tweets like howard kurtz joe
scarborough said hillary is shouting her
speech she has the floor a more
conversational tone might be better for
connecting with folks at home
and joe scarborough tweeted smile you
just had a big night
so women are furious feminists oh yeah
you wha
we never tell men to smile you just
always you're doing your toes to smile
you can own us like a woman
no
here's the thing too okay is it is it a
criticism that's only love that women no
i tell that to you all the time when
you're just you know when you're sitting
there and you're i'm like what's wrong
if if you're happy you forgot to tell
your friends you're very sensitive
though you're very sad i'm pretty
sensitive but it is true dennis prager
who's brilliant talks about how it's
your moral obligation to be happy
um and it's he makes a brilliant
argument for it i don't think you had to
paint that above like your doorway
coming in though that was
i don't think cross line there well
because i i need i need a shot in the
arm too with that when it happens it's
easy to get
negative yeah shot in the butt it's easy
to get negative when you when you have
um when you live in this kind of a world
we live in right so it's important and
it's not because of your happiness but
because of how it affects everybody
around you sure
so is this a criticism that's only lob
at hillary clinton we have this at
ladder with credit.com
along with a photoshop with some words
that we can't say on on terrestrial
radio no people say it to men too
however
is it something that most men would
think
is more becoming of a woman
yes
do men generally like women who are
happy
yes
is it
for a woman does it come across as more
[ __ ] for her to be serious in never
smiling than a man yeah yeah for because
for a man men are often stern men are
smiling carly fiorina got a lot of those
she got a lot of the same criticism
criticisms early on um but so did so is
rick santorum he's gotten that a lot
where he just comes across as grumpy as
curmudgeony that's true yeah people a
lot of people got
rand paul rand paul same thing with rand
paul same thing with bernie's it's gone
around but the truth is listen
if you have a man let's say a woman out
there and your husband says like hey hey
why don't you smile how about a smile a
pussycat
that's not him being sexist it doesn't
mean he doesn't like you he's trying to
help you for example
do men ever tell women tuck in your
shirt no how often has a wife said that
to her husband how often is a girlfriend
said that why because when a man looks
slobby doesn't tuck in a shirt i'm using
it as an example there could be
something else tie your shoes i don't
know
it is less attractive on a man in
particular
men like women who are happy as a
general rule that's not sexist so if i
like something and i'm saying hey why
don't you do this i said you know it
would make you more attractive
that's not someone who hates you that's
someone who wants you to do better
that's someone who's trying to improve
you and i think a big part of this to
feminism is intertwined with the
self-esteem generation and this is
something where my wife and i have
gotten into arguments about this
early on not so much but there's still
this tendency in women is that why can't
you just love me the way i am
listen if someone wants to change
certain things about you it doesn't mean
they don't love you it means they love
you more it means there are things they
want to improve doesn't mean they don't
love you
for who you are but there are going to
be things they don't like for some
reason women get upset when you do it
with them but it doesn't count when they
tell you they don't like it when you
leave your nose hairs in the sink but if
you say hey you know what maybe you
should smile a little more it's sexist
now that being said i have no problem
with uh sexist attacks towards hillary i
think they're funny and i think they
should be done early and often and will
do them but it was not sexist for
someone to tell her to smell tweet me at
s-crater do you think it's sexist to
tell a woman hey
you're coming across as off-putting
you're coming across as shrill
tweet me and let me know i don't know
have you ever run into that with uh with
uh anyone you know like yeah yeah and i
think i think what's funny about when
you go back to like the the relationship
thing is
looking at different relationships in
your life and realizing which ones
define like love as
hey if you love me you'll accept me
accept me for exactly who i am and don't
ask another thing of me and then there's
some i'm much more the guy who said hey
how could it be better for you what can
i do to change and that's kind of more
of a sign of love to me is it you know
is the improvement thing i don't know if
it's a guy and girl thing or not it's
kind of a i know they always get mad if
there's a criticism exclusive to women
feminists say that's not fair but there
are plenty of criticisms excuses to men
now that being said this isn't one of
those
right hey you're coming across as
yelling shrill it would help to smile
this is has been lobbed toward men but
there are criticisms that probably only
apply to women that don't apply to men
well sure but that doesn't mean it's
sexist
it just means it only applies in one
situation recognizing just like
recognizing the difference between white
and black people is not racist right
david duke is a racist someone who hates
black people because
because of right extra y factor and i
know you'll get people here going you're
a cook server won't you acknowledge your
blood people are less intelligent all
that stuff we get these people every now
and then come on listen i'm just not
your guy now that being said even if
that were true that's still not an
argument because you know what i don't
think less of the special needs people
who i work with i don't think of them as
less valuable as human beings you've
always treated me pretty well i've
treated you pretty well
i mean
you've treated courtney treats us both
very well this is true so very tolerant
just because so not only can you
recognize differences but you can
recognize that some races of people
might be inferior
in certain aspects of humanity for
example white people are slower than
black people every single world record
and speed ever is a black person
i don't know why
but they've done it that's not racist in
the same breath you can say well asians
tend to do higher on iq tests than black
and white i knew someone who genuinely
genuinely grew up thinking black people
had an extra muscle in their leg white
people that's a lot of people think that
they think there's something different
in the way their tibia connects
so so the point is proven to me that's
true the absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence
that do we have
is lauren coming on after this we have
one more segment all right so it's
important same thing if you're going to
talk about establishment these umbrella
terms we use a lot i think that's what
we should do for the next few shows
let's define these terms that are thrown
around racism sexism establishment mass
shooting we'll talk about that after the
break if it's not legally defined it's
easy to manipulate and that's where the
left lives we're going to break louder
with crowder stay tuned
and now dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
mr champion
very humbled and grateful that you asked
me to endorse you but i do have a few
concerns yes frankly this is a time to
voice him okay i know that some of what
you've done is
in the realm of political theater right
calling me a pedophile and what have you
but my main concern is that you will be
consistent with principles
that matter
to me as a christian conservative
frankly i'm gonna stop you right there
okay because truthfully i will read two
corinthians every day right okay because
that's what it's all about that's what
that's the whole thing right there okay
every day
i am so christian okay nobody's born no
but frank there's nobody more christian
than me i'm the guy
i believe you
this has been dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
okay business time really simple some of
you don't know where to find me
louderwithcrowder.com half a dozen to
ten articles every single day twitter
follow me at s crowder louder with
crowder podcast on itunes soundcloud or
any other podcatching device youtube.com
stevencrowder or you can type in
stevencrowder on facebook and be one of
the million plus fans or join the
mailing list there are so many ways for
you to stay connected you have no excuse
you have no excuse just like you have no
excuse for those rolls that are just
cascading over your belt buckle you
should be ashamed unless you're a lady
then you deserve get her a medal
so
wow
all right we are back not gay jared
thanks so much close your curtain behind
you it's bothering me it's all open and
it looks like it looks like
looks like hell so we were talking i
just got a direct message which is rare
during the live show someone who really
liked we were talking about it wasn't
quite clear in the last segment they
wanted that as a video clip
um
you know i was talking with my with my
dad about this because we were talking
about racism sexism you know it's people
just throw it out there nowadays you
know who must be the most racist sexist
people on the planet
are scientists oh okay doctor what were
we gonna say i'll say penguins i just
they come to mind as little prejudice
they're a little uppity they are a
little bit
and then they try to disguise they try
to play it off because they're they're
black and white
well i was going to say more so because
like they they're always
black tie
formal yeah it doesn't matter where they
go that's the thing you know
it's just like just every now and then
we want to see you put your guard down
penguins you don't need to wear the
tuxedo just relax by the couch
sit on an egg for a few weeks you don't
need the you don't need the tuxedo what
happened was they wore it once people
opened the doors for them
let them in the bank
they felt not judged for once and then
just couldn't they just they just they
ran with it
i really do you have you ever smelled
the penguin exhibit i've stopped
penguins
yeah this looks like oh get serious now
have you ever smelled a penguin exhibit
i have not it is particularly bad
i don't know if it's an oil you know
that makes them waterproof uh the
coating but penguins are really really
smelly
abnormally so even in the bird kingdom
they're like they're like the john
kasich of
of birds there we go they're like the
john kasich of flightless birds even
among flightless birds like that's as
useless as it gets there are also jerks
you know i have that stand-up bit i
don't usually talk about this on here
but you've seen it where we're talking
about all the cute animals and penguins
how they shove the nearest penguin off
the iceberg to check for seals which is
really awkward for that penguin if
there's a seal but even more worse
even worse if there is
it comes back super awkward you know
we'll talk if you come to the show in dc
next week at american university you'll
be able to hear the bits we go through
sea otters penguins dolphins
funny enough in the stand up a lot of
science in my stand-up
because there was i remember that when i
when i saw you live for the first time a
few weeks ago i dropped away
incredibly educated incredibly educated
appreciate that people learn a lot about
dolphins and omega fatty acids and
gluten and gluten and
veganism veganism and vegetarianism so
uh okay so we're talking about this it's
important to learn these terms that are
defined racism sexism is an umbrella
term establishment is an umbrella term
that's thrown around a lot today
um
people say that about marco rubio
violence is another one that like gun
violence shooting gun violence finds
another one that just kind of
comes in anything they want to or don't
want to especially christian social
justice warriors right throw that out
there yeah violence i've talked about
violence is not inherently immoral it's
not violence can be used to rape someone
or violence can be used to stop a rape
just like money money is not immoral
we had a pastor one time get up i
remember when i was in greenfield park
quebec and he just he just berated rich
people talked about how bad they were
you know for so i don't like the
prosperity preaching thing in the
christian set but i also don't like this
whole nobility in poverty that doesn't
help anybody either you know and you
talk about how bad rich people were and
i think a millionaire only wants another
million and then passed the hat
afterward to do missions work
and i made it a point to tell him why i
wasn't giving him any money
i went out of my way to say you know i
worked really hard for it which makes me
a bad person and he even i remember
on the podium what do you call it stage
podium pulpit i guess pulpit probably
misquoted the verse saying money is the
root of all evil that's not the verse
it's money is a root of all kinds of
evil meaning money is a potential one of
many different routes
the love of money that's right the love
of money
which basically goes back to idolatry so
it's just it's one of those things you
can use
you can take a million dollars and you
can put it out use it to put a hit on
somebody
or you can take a million dollars and
you can give it to charity or you can
you know help some people in need or you
can take that million dollars and put it
a hit out on somebody who needs it
i would never i would never imply never
ever imply like john kasich i'm talking
about someone like kony you know the
warlords
so
that's a good point we've released a
video this week and it's it's picking up
steam a lot vox released an anti-firearm
anti-second amendment video and it went
viral again a lot of conservatives
listening to rest really probably
haven't seen it but young people have it
had a lot of plays well up to half a
million or something like that it's
close to that pretty high
and i don't use the term propaganda
lightly okay it's important for
conservatives to understand this don't
call someone you disagree with a liar
generally give someone the benefit of
the doubt because when you encounter a
real liar like a hillary clinton
it it it um it bolsters your argument if
they just go well that's just that's
just donald trump he calls everyone a
liar he called ted cruz a liar he called
he's gonna call to hillary clinton a
liar you know what i mean donald trump
has called everyone a liar so him
calling hillary clinton a liar isn't
going to be that helpful
if you call everyone a liar it really
does water down your argument a lot of
the time people are just wrong
like your friends your social justice
friends they've been misled you have to
allow for that
it's one thing to get something wrong
it's one thing to proactively know the
truth ignore it that's a lie vox did
that they pushed propaganda they
deliberately misled by
in this video we rebutted it they
included statistics that were
overall gun
uh deaths in the united states
and then they did per capita and then he
talked about gun ownership but then they
never showed per capita gun owner uh gun
ownership across countries and their
correlation with gun crime
the united states bottom line the united
states does not have a gun problem with
law abiding citizens we are not the top
country in the world with gun related
homicides 80 of our gun-related
homicides are are drug related in some
form or another and with the increase in
purchasing of guns that we've seen over
the last decades there have been a
there's been a significant decrease in
overall violent crime so mass shootings
is a term that left us hide behind well
we don't really like to define it vox
used several different definitions of
mass shootings within their same video
but
violent crime or gun related homicide is
a legal term the fbi needs to have those
statistics so anytime you see somebody
using terms like establishment or mass
shooting or
racism or sexism anytime you notice a
pattern of somebody using terms that are
difficult to define or can be
subjectively defined depending on their
motive or depending on that situation
immediately you need to question it
and i will have to talk more about this
afterward but i wanted to get to the
establishment because john boehner
referred to ted cruz's lucifer this week
and um wants to trot out paul ryan oh my
gosh
i don't think paul ryan's a bad guy but
my gosh
talk about a wimp um
we'll talk more about that we have
lauren southern coming up after the
break to talk about her run-in with
angry feminists and the assault ladder
with crowder stay tuned
this is breaking news on louder with
crowler i'm perry matheson we take you
now to a republican party currently
underway
ugh it's nice just to relax i know the
cold air really contrasts with the water
tonight yeah it's just too much in there
for me oh hi there you guys are you're
oh a hot tub i didn't know we had one of
those here i would have brought my
trunks i tell you there's nothing better
than a good soak yeah that's right john
though my doctor advises against it you
know on account of the hemorrhoids oh
dear god well it looks like it's just us
boy so i think brief should work fine
let me hop on in there no you don't have
to you don't have really yeah you really
don't have to and you know it may seem
counter-intuitive but the hot water
really helps my ibs we'll keep you
updated as the republican party
progresses after this
whoa jared what are you doing shoot
megan with what my ar-15 where'd you get
it ai15.com oh there's another one
you got them thank god for ar15.com they
have ar-15 and accessories for sale and
the best advice there is on the web oh
no there's another one
you got him yeah with your what ar15
from where
that's the best place to go and that's
the takeaway because this commercial's
about to
the things stop i want to do
so glad to be back uh with our next
guest so she has been on the program
before but she was actually the news
story herself as opposed to reporting
the news this time you can watch her on
rebel media of course in canada or
follow her if you are stateside at
lauren underscore southern lauren
southern thank you for being with us
hi steven thanks for having me oh geez
look you're it's you're actually it's
not nearly as early as last time it
looks like there's light
yes there is it's nice and light outside
here okay so we have a bunch to get into
here but um we were supposed to have you
on and sorry that we had to bump you by
the way i think we explained it was just
a rough couple of weeks but um
you had a little bit of a run in
yourself so i want to know if there's
something developing here but for people
who don't know you went to a feminist
rally as you always do you're very
polite much more polite than i am and
there was a little bit of a of a
kerfuffle there was a there was a a dust
up a hootenanny that happened explain to
the audience
this one actually wasn't a feminist
rally this was supposedly an
anti-fascist rally there was supposed to
be a speaker in canada and i don't know
if he's a bachelor's or not i was just
curious to see what he had to say he's
running for the libertarian party in the
states augustus sole invictus very
controversial guy and he was actually
blocked from coming into the country and
his whole event was cancelled because
anti-fascists supposedly decided to shut
down his free speech shut down the forum
everything uh because they are so
against fascism right one second
so the ant anti-fascist protesters
these were people banning the guy from
speaking
yes okay yes
i know it's it's very interesting and
they had posted on their facebook page
that if he did end up getting into the
country to speak they were going to be
throwing feces at him they were going to
attack him one of the comments on the
page actually said the left needs to be
stop being afraid of using violence
against opinions they don't like
i don't think the left has ever been
afraid of using violence against
opinions they don't like that doesn't
even require an announcement it's just
stating a a factual uh reality
right so a lot of the people who were
going to be going to the speech there
were just a lot of libertarians in the
area including myself and we decided to
go for drinks that evening and the
anti-fascist protesters still showed up
to just our drink night in the area
where the speech was supposed to be
dressed fully in balklava's with cameras
they're all covering their faces and all
black if i were standing across the
street i would have thought they were
supposedly the fascist sure right right
and we got into a bit of a discussion
with them we're like you guys are
calling yourselves anti-fascists and
you're shutting down people's forum to
free speech how does that add up like
we're all very pro-speech people why not
go challenge this guy's ideas if you
don't agree with him why not right like
actually have a discussion
and i saw a few of the girls that i was
just there to record i had a friend
there who does some recording from every
once in a while so i was just recording
the conversation at first but then i saw
one of the girls who was at the [ __ ]
walk who had published a ton of slander
about me online she had sent a letter to
my boss she had sent a letter to
leaders of the libertarian party
of mine
oh something natasha catio i believe
pseudonym that's just his online he's
just messing with you oh you fell for it
oh gotcha
uh true fat suit you got there troll
level alpha okay oh she be well that's
true she's a lot bigger than that gay
jared they outweigh he would not do well
in a feminist mma tournament
he couldn't make the weight he'd be too
light okay so this girl has been
harassing you for a long time i want to
get to the
yeah okay
i don't mean harass okay she's been a
horrible witch with a capital b to you
is that okay can i say that
you're not a victim she's just rude and
she should smile more because i'm a
sexist so this girl is there and
bring us to i guess the the the sort of
climax here for people who don't know
because it's a good one so we we got
into a discussion on gender politics
and one of the girls said for something
we need to be feminists for all the
genders and i'm like oh so men and women
right
so two genders and that just
they snapped they were like what are you
talking about that is so transphobic how
can you say that i don't i don't
understand how it's transphobic
considering i don't know if trans people
want to be their own separate third
gender or want to be male or female it's
all very confusing for me
but well you have lots of trans friends
you're the one who introduced us to uh
theron meyer who we had on the show
and you're far more progressive on that
front so the last person i'd peg is
transphobic is is you simply for saying
male and female
right well that's what i accidentally
did i was like my trans friends wouldn't
consider me transphobic and they're like
that's like saying you have a black
friend so you're not a racist but it's a
perfectly legitimate argument if you
have like a bunch of if you have a bunch
of black friends if you hang out and i
wouldn't even be surprised if there was
there that night for drinks if you're
there with one of your best friends
who's a transsexual transgender that
means you probably don't hate them just
because they say that it doesn't make it
a less valid argument
well no you're obviously hanging out
with all your black and trans friends on
leashes just right well
i wouldn't in the trans community that's
just tuesday
this is true this is true if they want
it then it's all right yes but
anyways i'm just i'm like how is this
controversial saying there are only two
genders
and i just feel something that pour over
me and screaming around me and i'm like
oh my goodness did someone just pour
something on me and i'm drenched and the
guy beside me says you smell like eureka
piss lauren and the feminists around me
start laughing and pointing at me and
saying go to hell i hope that washed the
scum off you and i'm just like i i start
laughing well urine is sterile so
they have it's they're not wrong
it can be cleansing
okay do you okay do you think it was
actually earned because i know someone
said that but do you believe it was did
you smell it what what what uh do you
have any kind of proof or is it just a
hunch
i like i said i've said it online i
don't expect anyone to believe a single
thing i say unless i have 100
substantial evidence what i do have is
the people that were beside me that were
the witnesses that said they're almost
100 positive it's urine um and i
actually am talking to someone from a
testing lab right now on facebook who
we've kept my cameraman's clothes in a
bag
for uh it's been like two weeks now i
don't know if it'll still be able to be
tested but he's kept it like monica
lewinsky's blue dress and we're gonna
see if we can get it tested until then i
have no problem with people just saying
it was pop can you do that because i'm
not someone
i don't the the girl i'm talking to said
you can so we will try our best to get
100
evidence but i don't expect anyone to
believe me until i actually if there
were ever any burden of if it were you
ever needed any more evidence as to the
unrealistic standard of burden of proof
with conservatives
lauren southern ladies and gentlemen she
has her urine soaked clothing in a bag
which she will take to the lab whereas
feminists just yell rape on columbus at
columbia campus and it's written up or
virginia uh what was it university west
virginia was rolling stone i think so
colombia got in new york times that's
all they need
she needs to have a morgan freeman from
the dark knight and a secret underground
lab to prove that someone peed on her
thing is that there's somebody some
woman some hag of a feminist somewhere
right now watching this going
i shouldn't have done that
sorry what was that lauren you know that
is the really funny thing about this all
that's probably my favorite part is the
reaction online on twitter from left
ring media in canada
was all of them saying well she was
probably lying because she she probably
paid ezra lavon probably paid someone to
go and dump urine on her head they're
all saying that i've created this false
playground and it's just hilarious
because suddenly hashtag believe women
does not apply to me it's some
false flag that i paid someone to pour
urine on me and i'm lying about it and i
told them all i'm like you know what i
wish you had this level of skepticism
when dealing with other cases absolutely
emails telling stories this is great now
we know you have the capability of being
skeptical and questioning women's
stories now applied across the board
yes that is good you were really coming
into your own you know the first time
you were on your she was a little bit
more shy and you seem like you're you're
more fluid now do you feel like you're
getting more comfortable with the media
thing because you're you're really young
i mean you're still in school do you
feel like you've you've grown leaps and
bounds did you think the urine was like
the elixir
oh thank you steven um yeah i know i'd
say i'm getting a little more
comfortable with it yeah i'm only 20. a
lot of people think i'm like 30. it's
insane but it's the makeup it's hard to
guess with women with men the age shows
with women it's just hard
i'm just cheating yes yeah
it's it's a tough guess sorry go ahead
it's good though because um when people
think you're a little older they give
you a little more respect to your
opinions i think it should be the
substance of the argument but
unfortunately people do make that
judgment based on age as well no you're
absolutely right i mean when i signed i
was you know that fox i was 21. um i did
the just for laps we just told them that
with mike ward i was 18 but no nobody
ever found out until afterward remember
the little gray that i have here i've
had this since 21 so when i was 21
people assumed it was you know 28 and
i'm 28 people assumed typically
somewhere around there so um yeah the
one thing i don't like is when young
people use it as a gimmick and that was
one thing i never wanted to do because i
had to introduce little conservatives at
cpac who were 14 and i remember talking
with the organizers saying this is only
going to end badly
and most of them did all of them did
every single one of them did but
lauren's i didn't know she was did you
know she was 20. i thought she was like
22 23. oh okay so there you go lauren
yeah you could drink in my my opinion of
you she can drink yeah um well in canada
she can anyway sure so so urine so
is there any sorry any ramifications at
all are you you're not gonna press
charges you're just gonna
no the police did contact me because the
small asian girl that was with me there
we went out for drinks earlier she's a
candidate for the libertarian party uh
she pressed or she put in a police
report just to make sure that it was
there and they contacted me to press
charges i told them i wasn't really
interested in going forward because it
would be a one to two year court case
just because of how backed up the system
is sure and that system's probably
backed up from feminists filing assault
charges from tweets they get so i'm not
about to uh slow down that system even
more for something that i just had to
take a shower for i can ignore tweets i
can take showers when people throw piss
on me it is not that big of a deal i'm
not about to play professional victim
and i'm getting very tired of this
culture where people
run and whine to the police when they
are uh bumped in a crowd or have a
drinks built on them i don't want to be
that person even though this was
maliciously done
i honestly just don't care that much
that's true i understand someone says i
mean well the difference obviously when
i was repeatedly punched in the face
that's a little bit worse
oh yeah this is at the union rally in
detroit that's where that's where in
lansing sorry this happened a while ago
and that's where i get i get a little
bit peeved when people go violence at
school or i mean well you know i mean
even even milo god bless them sometimes
can be dramatic with that when they're
just yelling out they hate you i'm like
well that's not really assault um you
know someone who is who was like
viciously assaulted um and i don't even
want to follow report and it depends on
the the prosecuting attorney it's it's a
really corrupt legal system
yeah like you said some people um really
can bog it down they probably saw your
name and said ah it's another feminist
put it in the pile with the others so um
we want to continue on that train of
thought can we keep you for one more
segment yeah definitely lauren southern
no wait oh you were saying two minutes i
thought he was saying 20 seconds jared
doesn't have consistent signaling um
this is true okay so you were saying
that
and i want to get into that because i i
noticed you tweeted a lot about the
breitbart controversy shut up jared with
michelle fields now i understand where
you're coming from she wasn't hurt
however
there is however there was lewandowski
lied and said she wasn't there he never
met her she's a drama queen and uh
tennis wasn't there and of course they
were there and he was talking to them so
there there are lies there and um you
don't put your hands on a journalist for
asking an unfavorable question is it a
violent assault no i think there's
exaggeration but where do you line up on
that can you see both of those sides
well the issue i don't think it was an
assault at all i've had the exact same
thing happen to me while asking
questions to popular figures being
pushed out of the way i've had worse
things happen to my camera men who have
gotten bumped in things while they were
filming things with other journalists
around and that's just the life of a
journalist right
but with this one specifically both
sides obviously bugged me the biggest
thing about me is when it comes to
pressing charges over it the charges are
being pressed because she says she
didn't get an apology if your judgment
of women aren't charged
there aren't charges
okay
criminal complaint if your judgment of
what is criminal or not is based on
whether you get an apology or not it
isn't that serious
well i don't think
and i don't know michelle fields i know
ben obviously he's a friend and and um
obviously
and there's a lot of inside baseball
that i try and avoid on the program um
well you know we have to go back let's
talk about it when we come back because
i think there's a lot to dive into there
and i think you're right about most of
it uh
oh you're giving see now you're changing
the signals ladder with crowder we'll be
back with lauren southern stay tuned
jesse former governor of minnesota
ventura here the bond
going back to my original thought from
earlier in the program
there's also rumors that the gops
establishment hacks might try and try
out none other than mitt romney
mitt romney's a hack who never served
his country in an underwater demolitions
unit but jesse the bod and he has been
an integral part of the government
button fluoride in your tap
know the facts
hey crowderheads if you're listening to
this on itunes or soundcloud or maybe on
the youtube live stream because that's a
thing now you're missing so much content
at louderwithcrowder.com that's actually
the bulk of what me and my glorious team
not gay girl notwithstanding do on a
daily basis anywhere from 4 to 10
articles a day with commentary videos
gifs images and it's all free so if you
want to be up to date on the news and
entertain just add louder with
crowder.com to your rss feed go check it
every day it's free you get to support
the site and then you know maybe we'll
give you for some free stuff i don't
know maybe free college what are they
promising free college health care
i don't know they're probably we'll give
you that just
just bookmark it and we'll give it to
you that's a promise
all right we are back of course with
none other than lauren southern watch
her on rebel media if you are in canada
on the internets or follow her on
twitter at lauren underscore
southern glad to have you back okay we
got some tweets during the break lauren
someone said one of the biggest fans of
the show of course uh jimmy chewbacca
said please tell us lauren isn't a
trumpy which i know we talked about last
time um so i know you're libertarian but
you also enjoy the alt-right um so
that's got to be conflicting for you
the
the issue here is i'm i haven't
commented much on trump over the past
uh about a month ago i didn't really
comment on trump much but over the past
month i just have these people on my
feed that are so vitriolic towards him
it will literally block you if you say
anything remotely positive or in defense
with him and i'm finding myself being oh
that's a total opposite i'm sorry all i
get is like you know the you know the
cuck thing and you we've talked about
that i mean but i understand where
you're coming from too from the left i
admit the the rally thing makes me have
to defend him but you also have to
acknowledge that if you're going to get
mad at michelle fields you know trump
threatening to sue ted cruz unless he
apologizes
for using trump's quotes you would have
to say that's also problematic right
problematic i hate that word of course
okay dick move
illegal
i mean it
it's very hard for me obviously i would
want someone who is more libertarian
obviously
but you would say that's a problem
specifically right threatening to sue
ted cruz if he doesn't apologize for
running an ad of trump's quote side by
side
yeah that's petty it's very petty right
and there are very petty things going
back and forth in this entire election
however i don't i can't say i hate trump
i don't hate him i think he's really
shifted the overton window of the
discussion in political campaigns
and i enjoy that i think that's
something that needed to happen
and
if he is the nominee for the republicans
i don't think i will pull a
hashtag never trump i think i would
probably back him if he was chosen as
the nominee yeah well i think for the
vitriolic i've never done the never
trump thing i think the vitriolic hatred
that you're experiencing you know
multiply that by 10 and that's people
who who don't openly support trump who
are conservatives i mean my issue is you
know when i get emails from people
saying um
that if you don't get in line for trump
you know people like you need to be
purged from conservative media that's
where i go now i have to now i have to
be truthful better i mean you've heard
this show even we've insulted literally
everybody on the program
um including ted cruz for a long time
you know it's i do see where a lot of
people who are i see where you're coming
from when it comes to the whole you're
getting conservative all the time
yesterday i got at least a hundred
tweets of people calling from people
with the trump hat profiles calling me a
filthy jew i'm not even jewish i get
that all the time too yeah
must be horrible for shapiro because
he's actually jewish he's got a thick
skin but it still must hurt him a little
bit
see i don't know what to do it's the
strangest thing because it feels like
i'm a white person walking down the
street being called the n word and i'm
kind of like should i be offended should
i no no the general is never be offended
never be offended um
yeah you know that's the thing i like
that about trump too with the rally so
back to the michelle fields thing um i
understand where you're coming from
that's why i use the trump comparison
she didn't threaten to sue unless he
apologizes um she didn't press crim
file
char didn't press charges filed a
criminal complaint
she said her reasoning and this is again
why truth matters to me because like
kasich we just ragged on him all show i
can't stand him but the idea that george
soros gave him half a million dollars is
not true someone who worked for george
soros uh you know financial fund who's a
long-time republican donor gave 200 000
to john kasich's pack okay i don't like
john kasich
i don't want to defend him but that's
truth that still matters michelle fields
said she felt the need to to file a
criminal complaint because she was
thrown under the bus by her employers
and they ran the lie that she was never
even at the event or misidentified him
so she said she thought she was pressed
that's her employer's not lewandowski
and i can understand why this is one
thing i can't do but she said she had to
do it because if her employers are going
to run something was verifiably false
she felt the need to go on record saying
this is what happened and i i can prove
it so that was her argument and i think
that's what we'll see we'll see what
comes from that but i don't think that
lewandowski was malicious when he did
that i think he was moving her out of
the way i don't think that someone would
genuinely think to themselves hey i'm
trump's campaign manager you know what
would be a great idea grabbing the arm
of a journalist who's probably gonna
write a hit piece on me after this and
bruising it i don't think he thought
that at all i don't think if he could go
back and
uh
not even go near her i think he would
have done that i also understand why the
trump campaign didn't apologize because
if they apologized they would have been
admitting to nearly pulling her to the
ground which from the video the only
video we have that really shows what
happened that was not the case at all
she was not nearly pulled to the ground
which has been repeated on fox news by
shapiro which has been stated by
michelle herself in her breitbart
article so the exaggeration
really yeah there's exaggeration and
like i said as someone who has been
punched in the face repeatedly on camera
um that always bothers me
but i do think that is i mean if people
want to get mad at barack obama for not
allowing fox news donald trump is
absolutely the single most authoritarian
candidate in modern history when it
comes to journalism he just bans them
doesn't give you the right to be there
and um they retracted it but
i tend to believe the initial story um
when they said you know if we'd have
known it was a breitbart reporter we
wouldn't have done that what is wrong is
to in any instance you see everyone was
asking him
uh presidential candidate questions to
grab her and single her out because it
was an uncomfortable question that is
something that in the united states you
know same reason we have the first
amendment on free speech freedom of the
press is just as important and and that
that is an issue and then when someone
lies about it i have a problem with it i
do agree with you she probably wasn't
hurt and wasn't anywhere near thrown to
the ground but um
that's not okay yeah
i'd have to i don't know if it was
specifically because it was an
uncomfortable question if that was the
case obviously i'd like to hear trump's
opinions on all questions i'd like him
to answer those right um
however yeah the exaggeration it was a
non-story until
you had the audio tape and the
exaggerations released if it were just
that small video clip that was released
no one would have cared if it were not
lewandowski that did that and if it were
a certain secret service agent no one
would have cared it was because it was a
public figure and i'm finding a lot of
the people that really really hate trump
are just jumping on this and saying it
was an assault it's i think you've made
a lot of assumptions there i think
you've made a lot of assumptions there
to be fair ben shapiro has supported
trump for a long time on a lot of issues
and now doesn't and he had a problem
with that ben shapiro was a harvard law
group
i'm not just talking about shapiro at
all right i listen to shapiro all the
time i don't think he's right on this
issue but i'm saying people like him
they wouldn't not care if it were
someone else if barack obama's people
did that because someone asked barack
obama about bill ayers i think they'd
have a problem with it i don't know but
i agree with you there's exaggeration
all around and this campaign is a circus
um here oh gosh let's go to break lauren
southern uh we'll bring you back soon
and talk more about urine when you get
the the lab analysis we'll be back
loser in his her or z's mother's
basement watching this on the youtube
live stream listen youtube is great but
it's not always super convenient if
you're on the go that's why this show
which is actually syndicated as a radio
show is available on itunes soundcloud
or any kind of podcatcher that you
android users for free just search lotto
with crowder find it subscribe you get
the full show and some exclusive content
that you actually won't hear on youtube
including giveaways extra commercials me
beating not gay jared within an inch of
his life but it's okay he always comes
back into work so i can fire him so
itunes soundcloud or podcatcher get the
full show and listen to louder with
crowder on the go if you don't you're
probably a racist rapist
this is breaking news on louder with
crowler i'm perry mallison we take you
now to a republican party currently
underway
yeah i know i just don't even know what
we're going to do it's such a hard
situation what's that
john
kasich out there
we'll keep you updated as the republican
party progresses after this
you've found yourself at the junction
where worlds meet
politics civility how about honesty in
this country folks entertainment i don't
like entertainment and a whole bunch of
other stuff
it's about having a healthy body image
you have a very unhealthy body you
should have a horrible body in it not a
big helmet through the market
we are definitely going to get letters
you're listening to talk radio's
strangest
you're getting louder with crowder
all right we're back
in the third hour coming up uh after
at the bottom of the hour we have
courtney courtney kirchhoff courtney
scoffs on twitter for people to follow
and
read her article about why
dear bernie sanders voters you are not
men
amen pretty incendiary of course
producing with me in studio as always is
not gay jared you can follow him on
twitter
he is not gay i fulfilled all my legal
obligations draw your own conclusions
so we've been talking about defining
words a lot this week
and lauren was on i actually i think
lauren is pretty balanced in her
approach on the trump side which i
appreciate i think we try to be too i
mean if people go back before the trump
surge we got so much crap for being
critical of ted cruz where we were
saying because at that point we didn't
think he was the best guy to win a
general right even at this point he's
not the best guy to win a general um the
numbers we have say he would probably be
better than trump but i fully
acknowledge he's not the best guy out
there to win a general election i think
we had some other choices who could have
done better and people got so mad at us
for saying that people get so mad when
it's finally their candidate
um
who had the who would you say had the
best sense of probably ted cruz people
had have a better sense of humor then
i'm trying to think people got rubio
people were really upset when we made
fun of rubio
um
rand paul supporters
would get upset donald trump supporters
can't handle any of it
who would you say
handled it in
you know with with the best spirit
gosh um
i don't know i don't think carly fiorina
really had enough of a following when we
were kind of
you know talking about her
i don't think none of them really stick
out in my mind as people who can really
just really didn't care i don't know i
would say now now between trump and cruz
i think the cruise people are more open
to jokes and criticism yeah i think so i
mean
just the debate one with the uh the
people thought he had he was eating a
booger if you type in tankers it's a
booger on youtube it's the first thing
pops up from the debate and and you know
i don't know if you ever addressed it i
don't know if you hate it
one of those things you just don't want
to address no you just know
but could you imagine move on down the
trail could you imagine if that happened
to trump though oh my gosh oh you're
getting focused off the issues
um
i'm still thinking about that little
that little little scary guy just kind
of going around and never really quite
cooperating
yeah ted cruz it is a really weird clip
but a term that's thrown around now
right establishment when we're talking
about brokered contested convention
so uh that's a term that's not really
defined like marco ruby people say
establishment listen marco rubio
i i hate i can't stand that he was a
part of the gang of eight okay that
bothers me
but he took out charlie crist that was
the seat he took if you want to talk
about establishment look up the
definition
christ
is the person you'll see next to it
uh john boehner mitch mcconnell these
are people john mccain of course
people who are career politicians
you need to define the term
establishment because when you have the
establishment saying ted cruz is lucifer
and saying they think they might be able
to cut deals with
donald trump
the term has lost all meaning it's a
term that is used right now if you hear
someone using it a lot without defining
it and we don't really use that term on
here very much i will use it when
talking about john boehner i will use it
when talking about someone like a mitch
mcconnell jeb bush yes
dynasty
paul ryan now but there was a time where
he wasn't i just think he's a pansy i
just don't like paul ryan i don't hate
him
i just don't personally like him but we
don't want to destroy all republicans
you don't want to destroy all
conservatives i wrote about that listen
ted cruz has to go back to the senate
okay now if you're going to just if
you're going to call him just a liar you
know those are character assaults that
go back with him to the senate the guy
has a 97 percent consistency rating more
than any politician in modern american
history if you believe he's a liar then
then there is no one who's who's honest
um marco rubio
he probably won't go back because unlike
ted cruz that's a big that's actually a
big study in the difference of winning
and losing your home state people who
voted for ted cruz in texas i know that
necessarily wouldn't play well in a
general people who voted for him got
what they wanted and so ted cruz won by
a significant margin in his home state
people who voted for rubio and florida
felt a little bit betrayed
now do i think marco rubio is not
conservative
i here's the thing he's been pretty
consistent on a lot of other issues and
he made a big mistake with the gang of
eight you need to look at the context of
what happened there barack obama said if
someone gave me some comprehensive
immigration reform something bipartisan
i would sign it tomorrow and i think
marco rubio thought he was calling his
bluff and he did and it didn't go
through
so it was wrong
but it's not the same as a boehner or
mccain or a kasich who has consistently
concede concede conceived will not even
conceive proactively
plotted against republicans and
conservatives
but man if you want to talk about
destroying the establishment so let's
talk about the establishment people who
are career politicians people who want
to be moderate people who want to make
deals people who tell you it's you need
to be reasonable in government who don't
really believe that you can repeal who
don't really believe that you can defund
those are establishment people those
people have always hated ted cruz if you
want to talk about burning down the
establishment
i don't think there could be any
more to talk about rubbing salt in a
wound would be a brokered convention
putting or putting it into a
head-to-head and the delegates
re-pledged to ted cruz and they have to
back ted cruz who stood up on stage and
called them liars
and remember he called mitch mcconnell a
liar and john boehner called him lucifer
donald trump said i had a very good call
with mitch mcconnell can you believe how
rude ted cruz is to mitch mc remember
donald trump sided with mitch mcconnell
when ted cruz said he was alive the
reason john boehner thinks ted cruz is
lucifer is because of his staunch
opposition trying to repeal obamacare
and the government shutdown so the
reason john boehner you know for example
if someone calls ted cruz lucifer a
liberal because ted cruz is remarkably
pro-life well okay you expect that but
john boehner is mad at ted cruz
for doing the things that everyone
whether you're voting trump or cruz you
hope they do right i think most people
voting trump would still i would i would
like to think you still probably aren't
a huge fan of
obamacare
you still probably
aren't upset with the government
shutdown you probably want to decrease
spending i think most trump voters want
that right i don't think trump voters
are necessarily liberal i think they
believe some things in trump that i
don't
but i think people voting for trump or
ted cruz want those things
they just happen to believe one person
over the other john boehner mitch
mcconnell paul ryan hate ted cruz
because he has stood for those things
that you want in a candidate
so that's important to note so when
defining establishment you have to know
who they are why they hate the people
that they hate and then say okay if
that's my problem within the party right
now who do i believe
will stick it to them or deconstruct the
establishment the most
if you if your goal is to upset and you
hate the establishment again i'm not
telling you i think it's silly too when
people just act like the establishment
must all be in one mindset about what
they want either i mean these are a lot
of different people what gingrich wants
could be completely different than what
bob dole thinks you know
any agenda he might have up his sleeve
so it's kind of like you talk about it
like this big boogie monster that's out
to get that's this one you know it's
like the it's like the nazi regime all
kind of you know intertwined and
coordinated and you know
posed to get something or you get what
they want
exactly they probably agree it's
probably not true it's not in the dudu
it's like the you know the fake moon
landing or area 51 at some point if
there's a conspiracy that big someone's
going to talk
that's why the only conspiracy that i
really give any credence is the
clinton's killing people because no one
can talk because they're dead
so it's the most plausible and there's
that place out there in california where
they all get together and sing oh oh
bohemian grove yeah there is bohemian
grove that does exist for sure and
that's for people who don't know it's a
weird weird thing
and they burn this like this coffin and
effigy to this kind of owl looking god
it really is weird because why not
because why not but it doesn't
necessarily mean that they're meeting
with with uh globalists who are trying
to put florida in your tap as a
government form of mind control it could
just be a fraternity for really rich and
powerful people you know like skull and
bones um or like the freemasons i mean
that's not a conspiracy right you can
say these things exist but to make the
leap that they're sacrificing people or
they're all having secret meetings to
take over the world
that's a leap that for me requires a
little bit of substantiation if we're
hopping on board that crazy train so
hopefully this has helped where people
throw on the term establishment my only
thing i don't want to tell you listen i
don't want to tell you how to vote i
don't want to tell you who to vote for
you know we're island up i've been
honest about it i really felt the need
to defend donald trump with the rally
issue um listen free speech is free
speech here's the deal and this is what
bothered me about ted cruz for talking
about lobbying when ted cruz came out
first first off the first thing he did
was condemn the violent protesters
so
if you're not aware of that check your
news source because the first thing ted
cruz said is they need to be held
accountable and then he said but the the
environment from a campaign comes from
the top down
which i think he fired his guy when the
guy uh what was his name ah gosh i
forgot the name of the guy who tweeted
the thing about marco rubio
oh yeah yeah i can't remember i forgot
his name there's so many names now uh he
fired him because he thought it was
wrong
so
that's what he said i wish he hadn't
said that though i wish he would have
just talked about the protesters and how
wrong they were because that was a real
opportunity what ted cruz what i would
have advised him to say is okay listen
they're going to try and say your
anti-free speech which he's not if you
look at how he acted as a lawyer
he should have said listen
you have
your speech whatever you say regardless
of how offensive is protected under the
first amendment
acts of unprovoked violence are not
period whatever side you line up
that's what you say
now the one thing with it with the trump
rally is you know when you do say
punch a guy and i'll pay your legal fees
we've had to defend against the silly
leftist argument if you you'll fire in a
crowded theater and i've always said
well that's because that's a call to
action that's not speech that's
encouraging people to do something which
could in turn be dangerous or deadly are
you getting into that territory when
offering to pay someone legal fees for
committing assault
one could argue that and it makes it
hard for free speech advocates to say no
no there's a complete solid leg to stand
on here but those protesters in chicago
the left
they need to be
you need to take direct aim on them
no pity
and you cannot excuse it regardless of
whether you like trump or not that was
just a horrible horrible example of
modern progressivism in american
politics and we'll talk more about that
after the break
and now dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
of course mr trump is also a concern
that you've praised
single-payer or nationalized health care
plans as recently as
only several months ago
and i would need to in
clear conscience believe that you've had
a change of heart and said listen okay
frankly that was a different time that
was what canada was doing now canada
what what do they do what's canada doing
they're doing nothing okay so i could
change with that all right i don't need
a plan like canada it worked for a time
it doesn't work now i am gonna do so
much ben
i have to do so much for healthcare you
you're a sir i'm your guy good enough
for me
this has been dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
hey if you're listening to or watching
this podcast there's a strong chance
that you are not yet following me on
twitter at s crowder where i'm tweeting
all day long i'm ticking off the social
justice warriors you should see the
amount of hate i get on there far far
far worse than any fat sports
illustrated model or black lives matter
charlatan so listen it's free you get to
be entertained and you can chime in also
if you're following me on twitter you
can send me your tweets and maybe you'll
be lucky enough and i mean lucky enough
because i have a lot of followers okay
that they call me the follower machine
to have your tweet to me or not gay
jared included in a rockinest tweet of
the week so follow me on twitter at s
crowder if not
i don't want to say i have sights on
your mother but
oh she's dead
you're just saying that because i made a
mom joke no she's really dead well you
kind of walked into it
oh right before i bring on our next
guest who is a regular someone tweeted
me steven watching your show on youtube
what would be your response to people
who say that trump is hitler that's just
silly
it's just silly listen i don't have to
trump doesn't have to be my guy to
defend him from baseless attacks just
like i don't have to like john kasich to
say don't lie about the fact that soros
gave him a bag of cash that's also not
true so i i just think truth i don't
know i just think truth matters more
than than all of us and i think all
around fashion hippie you my
old-fashioned nippy okay we have to
bring on our next guest and when you
hear this you know
that means
that it's at courtney scoffs on twitter
courtney kirchhoff are you with us
oh oh look at you now you're all tanned
that's true from the vacation that's
right
courtney people comment every week call
it like a ghost
you yeah that's i i try to blame the
white balance i just haven't figured it
out yet no really he has no soul that's
true there you go accordion we don't
even have to tell her to smile because
she already is look at that okay we
pulled that do you think that's sexist
when people say hey hillary you should
you should probably smile more if a guy
says hey you have a pretty smile you
should smile more it's nice i like it
when people tell me i'm a pretty smile
what do you think it's a guy okay
there you go yeah right from her
speaking of guys you penned uh
a letter this week from a female
perspective to bernie sanders i've
written about this several times from a
male perspective and then we got on the
phone and you went into a rant and i
said this needs a female perspective so
tell p it's called what do i have it
dear dear man who vote bernie sanders
you're not men at all and you received
so much hate mail
i did from a lot of men who would who
who somehow were trying to defend their
manhood by saying no but really i am a
man just because i want bernie sanders
doesn't mean i'm not a man like okay i'm
not even gonna i'm not even gonna give
that a response
i only have time for real men if i'm
gonna respond to a tweet or a facebook
message or a email like no no no i even
had some wives like well my husband
works he's full-time and he volunteers
but he's voting for bernie sanders and
how dare you like
really
yeah i don't think your husband's
volunteering i think he can go on down
to the local gay bar and find him
ducking you that's what i think okay so
you wrote this and i've talked about
this i don't believe that in 2016 you
can be
uh a man and be an actual full-fledged
progressive i don't mean be kind of like
a a
a liberal maybe pro abortion or things i
mean full-on bernie socialist i've
written about that what was your main
point here in this article that people
hated you so much
well the idea that men have to provide
for themselves and provide for their
family i can just i can see myself on
the camera and it's very distracting
um because she's so good-looking that's
why
i got this tan i got the vitamin d
watch this is going to become a gif and
then everyone the the rumors of do it
again in full shot there you go
all right go ahead courtney try not to
be distracted
yeah
men don't need other men to provide for
them or their families they also don't
need a politician to
demand that other people
give no demand that their tax dollars be
taken to give to other people who refuse
to work for them to work for themselves
so real men provide for themselves
provide for their families they don't
whine they don't say it's not fair that
so-and-so has more they don't excuse why
they're not successful or blame it on
white privilege they don't do that they
say screw it i see a challenge challenge
accepted i'm gonna go for it i'm gonna
be successful despite all of these
things that i have going against me
bernie sanders voters don't do that they
believe barack obama they believe bernie
sanders when they say oh the deck is
stacked against you you didn't build
that we can help you
you deserve your fair share and these
rich people who have who've just
glided through life they're gonna
they're gonna pay for you it's it's okay
we're gonna take care of you that's not
a man that's a [ __ ] and i'm not sorry
i'm not sorry
uh well do we i don't think we have to
beep that no
no i think it's only if i'm referring to
that now yeah stop it
stop it because i know courtney will go
there she's a she's a lady but she's
she's a lady who's willing she will go
there
and i don't want her to go there right
now yeah i agree with you i agree with
you and i i just don't have a lot in
common with with guys like that
um and i think you can have it with
wealthy people too i mean they think you
say that with rich guys who feel you
have to prove because some things have
been handed to them as opposed to people
who are self-built but particularly it
is the ideology of a bernie voter to
subscribe to it you have to believe that
someone else is pulling the strings and
it's not in your control and i just see
that as anti-rugged individualist but as
a woman is it does it actually
like could you ever date
a leftist
i don't think so no
you choked on your words
if i were to see like a guy pull up in a
prius with a bernie sanders sticker or
um a darwin fish instead of the jesus
fish it we're done
you know we're done
yeah i
i couldn't i could and it's not anything
against people who drive priuses some
people like the car fine but no nobody
likes the car well caesar if you're a
people pleaser and you want people to
like you and you want everybody to know
how much you care for the poor or
whatever i i
can't i can't it's gross well you want
someone who cares for the poor you just
don't want someone who advertises it to
pick up truth okay look it if you care
for the poor great care for the poor
with your own money don't mandate other
people's money go to something that you
feel like it's a charity
yeah
i love how they separate that as a
fiscal issue well isn't theft kind of a
moral issue wouldn't we put that on the
on that side of the ledger um yeah it's
it's it's interesting to hear a woman
say that because my dad and i have
talked about that as men but now is this
something that i know when we write
about these things sometimes we think up
ideas for columns is this something that
has been percolating for a while you've
always felt that way and it was just
sort of sort of cathartic to put it to
paper or did was it in aha
i know i've always thought this i kind
of think liberal man is an oxymoron i
don't think
you can be a liberal
and be a man and i know and i mean that
a
masculine you can't be masculine you can
be a male adult but i don't think of you
as being masculine if
if you espouse liberal ideas and if you
live by the liberal ideas there are a
lot of successful men successful people
who
say liberal things but they don't
they aren't liberal in their own lives
they're conservative in their own lives
they're men in their own lives but if
you can just if you just even uh no i i
i i i there's a long way around to
express her disgust but that's true greg
gutfeld made that point that anyone
who's successful had to do so through
the pillars of conservatism of of taking
upon themselves and personal
responsibility um i wish i could find
that but greg got felt google it at
prager university
university guy does some great stuff
okay courtney we'll bring you on after
this break to anger some more men and
maybe find some suitors louder with
crowder stay tuned for more courtney
this is jesse former governor of
minnesota ventura here the bond with the
facts
talking again about the gop
establishment hacks
who have been rumored to maybe even try
and trot out
jeb bush at a brokered convention
the fact is jeb bush has been a puppet
for the establishment backtax for years
who have vampires your kids with
xenoestrogens and chemicals that
contribute to adhd
and mind control chemical agents forcing
them to go on dangerous medications like
real and and adderall but the good news
is that you can fix your child's problem
with some syrup that i sell at
jesseventraw.com
know the facts
steven crowder here hey jared what are
you doing i'm just having trouble
getting through this book that's because
you can't read i know you should have
used freedom project academy freedom
what freedom project academy just go to
fpeusa.org it's a fully accredited
private online school no common core and
absolutely no government funding
whatsoever all the classes are taught
live online kindergarten through high
school with real teachers based around
the country so through freedom projects
classical curriculum students master the
basics like math english history science
alongside the more commonly neglected
courses like logic you're not getting
that in a lot of schools economics
american studies in latin all of which
foster the long-lost art of critical
thinking and create leaders for tomorrow
all classes are recorded to be viewed 24
7 and you can get your very own sneak
peek of any class or professor at
fpeusa.org
open enrollment runs march through july
but classes always fill up fast now do
you have your ged equivalency jared no
is that important i think so i mean you
might want to give them a call that's
freedom project academy at fpeusa.org
i see that action over there
i don't like it i do it for our guests
courtney
at courtney scoffs on twitter for those
who don't know is flexing my pecs
because listen she's not dating anybody
it's it's the closest thing that she
gets to um a little bit of fun you're
welcome
yeah
i'll send it i'll send a text to hillary
later and say you know the nice all the
nice things that you do flexing my pecs
i yes that's uh it's something that i
something that i i do on my own time
it's a skill like anything i'm sure i'm
sure sometimes you do it my time lauren
southern already got the gift up of me
being gay right away she is so quick
um
everyone's trying to set up my friend
gerald morgan we've had him on the show
they're always going like fan in my
family what about courtney what about
what about lauren because they're like
you know he's conservative these women
are conservative and it's just they're
always every time i got like three
comments same thing with you i think you
and jeremy hit it off but you know
you're a catholic and he's not
um so there's that it's like i've never
talked to gerald
gerald's a good guy but he's not he's
actually he's a pretty brilliant guy
when it comes to theology and he went to
notre dame and he is not a catholic he
doesn't hate catholics but he will argue
why it's wrong and he is very good at it
um so that's why it might be tough or he
might challenge you and you guys might
have a great conversation one of you
might maybe you convert him and next
thing you know he's um he's like
screaming for the pope like the beatles
fans when it comes to stateside you know
you you've written about the pope quite
a bit you've been pretty peeved with
them
yeah there have been a few times just
like really seriously there's
plenty of other things that we could
discuss
global warming we're going to do that
really i think we need a new segment
called really seriously with courtney
scott really really seriously seriously
seth meyers has had a lot of stuff but i
think ours would be better because i
mean it's
what she's doing
well it's like seth meyers and you add
breasts
and you add a woman and you add
intelligence
and you add breasts
i like that in this day and age you have
to include adding a woman after adding
breasts because breasts anymore doesn't
mean that you're a woman well that was
going to be my question because you said
you know it's anti-rugged individualist
new bernie voters so what about what
about caitlyn jenner i mean still has a
penis of course and
said that we need to get back to
constitutionalism like ted cruz would
you say that bert that that caitlyn
jenner
in the newest turn of events
is more of a man
more masculine
as a faux woman than than bernie sanders
voters man i don't know because he's
he's kind of forged his own path he's
made his own money he's not demanding
that other people give
he's not demanding that
everyone pay their fair share and you
know he wears a dress
well then he got boobs did he get boobs
or did he just press it together he
forged those as well did he actually buy
breasts or is he just pushing him no i
think he bought them
he's got the money courtney can you
confirm do you know
i have not looked into this i feel like
it's the episode my hands have been here
for way too long they've been drinking
there's a gift there that's happening
it's the episode of seinfeld are they
real are they not jerry i got it not
real yeah no i don't anyway but still
has the bottom most transsexuals do not
do the bottom surgery so
okay so you wrote about this you got a
lot of a lot of hate mail um
from a lot of men i got a lot of hate
mail for beyonce too did you get a lot
of hate mail from women for your article
actually that's interesting so you get a
lot of hate mail from gay men from gay
black men gay black men continue
it's just deray with a bunch of fake
accounts
it was ironically a bunch of people
calling me ugly and they were using like
eggs the egg twitter
um oh oh well they haven't really filled
it out they haven't yet or beyonce and
they were calling me ugly like okay
really all right really seriously
so the guy looks like an egg i've gotten
a lot of hate mail from guys
saying that you know how dare i
i'm a cave woman how dare i say that
they're not men
i just and again i say it just goes to
my point if dare you
how dare you
exactly i thought you were cueing me for
that
i was oh okay there you go so what if
it's guys who got mad not women
some women some wives some why i want to
say like three
maybe three women but majority has been
has been men i think it's one of those
things like you said even if there are
some successful people who try and
espouse leftism they don't live that way
i think it's probably the same with a
lot of women even though they claim they
like a progressive guy and they like the
guy with the handlebar mustache and the
bernie sticker they don't really want a
guy who when something goes bump in the
night he's hiding in the closet and
shoving her down the stairs like it's a
lifetime movie and she's pregnant
well here's one of the reasons i don't
like feminism i think it's unfair to men
because feminists have said well they
want this certain type of guy they
they've said that they want as women to
take the lead
that's
unfortunate because that's not what they
actually want um bro tip to the guys out
there a lot of times women don't
actually know what they want until they
see it and i know i'm sorry i i
apologize for my gender we don't always
know
so women like men who are strong they
like men who take direction they like
men who make decisions they like men who
are decisive
that doesn't mean that they're going to
beat you over the head and drag them
into the cave that just means that
they're good hunter-gatherers they're
good providers women are hard-wired to
want that
so bernie sanders voters who are whiny
and wimpy and they i want my fair share
i just you know white privilege i don't
have it and i don't think it's fair it's
just
so on a scale from um on a scale from
jared's social justice friend hipster
feminist you know who wants to check his
privilege for you well i don't know
about that all the way to the scale of
you know donald trump you need to treat
women like
crap
where do you fall on that scale
you've heard that quote right you got to
treat him like shh that's what donald
trump said which
i think i don't think that should be
used against him because how many times
has donald trump been married
three that'll look kind of yeah that
might answer your question yeah that's
why he cheated on them he he slept with
other men's wives as well
so there is that so that i think that's
important though to note because a lot
of people think well you're just no
we're not saying you need a trash bag
either that's not masculine no there's a
big difference between you don't need to
trash bag there's a difference between
being a leader
and being a jerk there's a difference
between being decisive and being a
and i can't say it
you can't
being a man doesn't mean that you're
just bossy and and asserting your
manliness all the time means you're
confident in yourself
men who have to assert their math their
manliness generally are very scared yeah
yeah it's true
yeah if anyone says you know aren't i
powerful don't you think i'm powerful
aren't i strong that's a guy who hasn't
who has some issues and a guy who's
probably never you know never been in a
real conflict um and i think it's
important to note that because you have
a lot of people who will go too far the
other way and thinking you treat women
like crap or think that you think this
false sense of machismo you know there
are men that's overcompensating yes
exactly i mean there are men who can
just chug beer and burp and swear and
hunt and their families are falling
apart and their kids are losers and
their wives hate them that's not a man
and you can have a computer nerd who's
very strong and people do well and
there's leadership um right and i know
we agree with that in principle but i
just want for people out there who hear
this so she just wants to she wants to
bully you don't want some douchey bro an
affliction rhinestone t-shirt with a
fake tan
no and there's
and i was very careful my article to
define what i believe is masculinity i
didn't say someone who's gross
it's not someone who who goes to the bar
drinks a bunch of beer throws some shots
burps that's that's gross
right and masculinity isn't gross it's
it's complementarianism i mean as
christians people talk about men and
women compliment each other and hate
each other right and to deny that again
it's just like to deny the evolutionary
you know the biological evolutionary
mechanism of
generalizations that people make and
people try and make you feel guilty for
making generalizations i mean it's a
generalization for a man to open a door
for a woman because hey i'm stronger i'm
a man it's easier for me and it's
respectful to a woman those same people
deny the hard wiring that men and women
are different and we should use that
synergy to complement each other and
that's i think why feminism is so is so
corrosive to
society for women in particular
well and feminists aren't happy either
they should so
they should smile can they i mean
they're just they're just miserable all
the time and sometimes what i try to ask
people when i try to define for myself
what do i want do i want to be right do
i want to be powerful do i want to be
controlled or do i want to be happy
and you can't always have all of those
things so we have to decide as women and
as men what's more important
are we going to be right are we going to
be happy do we need to have that big
powerful career is that going to make
you happy because a lot of women they go
for that and when they're about 40 they
don't have a family they're not happy no
so
that's true they've done everything
feminism has told them to do and they're
miserable right
yeah that's that's a good point and i
you can't have it all i mean my wife and
i you know we don't have children and so
she works a lot and i work a lot and we
know that it's it's not balanced and
eventually we're going to have to to
remedy that particularly if we have kids
that's why we're doing it now so that
she can stay home that's been our plan
for a long time
i mean she wouldn't have to work as much
but she's worked for this you know
basically she's in a top position at a
company where
she it's a very it would take a long
time to fill this role and you know she
has equity in a company she's very
successful and she can't stand feminists
um
but yeah that's that's a good point and
um and you're a working woman too which
is why it's so interesting coming from
you because people can't say that you're
barefoot in the kitchen pregnant
yeah but i'm i'm
i'm working because i have to i never
wanted to be a career woman that was
never in my plan no it was never a plan
she hates working for me do you hear
this not get jared
gotcha naked jared knows knows what we
put up with with you sometimes and it's
not and i love working for you but i
would
i wanted to be the mom and the wife i
love this man
and i will go
to the hill
calvary and back with him
to get my next paycheck
yeah oh well okay this has gotten
uncomfortable
because um
courtney can be mean not okay jared you
just you just you just cower in fear i
yes sir yeah she does
that's what she does
uh which funny he's not a bernie voter
no it is it's f well it is it's one of
those things where i think if people
really read the article and they
understand where you're coming from
there is a lot of insight to take from
it and i think a lot of women are coming
to the realization we just talked with
lauren southern i think a lot of women
unfortunately come to it a little bit
late you know they come to it in their
mid-30s and their window is passed and
um all of a sudden they realized that
the guys who were white knighting and
supporting their their blue hair uh wild
boar like features at the feminist film
festival all of a sudden they're not
around anymore because they found wives
and
it's it's sad
what why are you laughing while poor
because it's funny i've got that mental
image they do feminists remind me of
wild whip away
well they're fat they're poor and
they're they're prickly they're prickly
like wild boar
they don't shake they don't wax i don't
get that i don't understand that how is
that oppression can you explain that to
me as a woman how could any woman see
that as oppression
oh because they're
they believe that beauty is only for
other men
now
what women find attractive is not
necessarily looks and men it's their
success and men don't have any problem
being successful nor do women have any
problem telling them to be successful
but for
a man to say i like a woman who doesn't
have hairy blue armpits that's
in the mind of a feminist
oppression patriarchy
it is the patriarchy
you're taking more effort to to
to not
your anti-hygiene requires more effort
than just basic hygiene and i want to
know why blue and who thought of it who
thought you know what would be a great
idea is to grow out my armpit hair super
long and dye it a rainbow color
someone thought of it i'm going to go
with him i'm going to go with elena
dunham yeah as she was sitting on the
toilet eating cake oh my gosh what kind
of thoughts do you have when you're
doing that only gross ones yeah there's
nothing good can come of that that's one
of those things i don't you know i don't
blame women for being women and men
should stop being blamed for being men
if a man says you know it'd be nicer if
you smiled more that's not someone who
hates you just like if a woman says hey
why don't you get off the couch and go
do something that's not a woman who
hates a man that's trying to better
someone which you should be doing for
yourself all right so courtney
at courtney scoffs you're going to have
some some uh some uh some dreams here no
some people are probably going to want
to date you so let's follow up on that
well i've actually had
a lot of guys say hey it was funny i
need to take a screen capture because
i'll have one tweet that says how dare
you are gonna make it we have to go we
have to go no okay courtney scoffs if
you want to date her will air it next
stay tuned
so
and now dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
of course there's also the matter mr
trump that you've been somewhat divisive
in your language and i understand that
as
a political tactic
but as christians we are called to be
good to one another
and to uplift each other and i need to
believe that you will do that as
president of this great country that i
saw what who's been more united than me
okay everyone is gonna be so united okay
i don't talk bad about anybody okay
every i make friends with everybody okay
everyone they call me the friend making
me sheet
you then call
megan kelly and bimbo and texas a liar
and
me a pedophile okay listen mega kelly is
a bibo
ted cruz is a liar the pedophile thing
listen okay it's politics okay i don't
know what you listen are you having sex
with little kids i don't think so i
don't know okay nobody could know all
right so it's not wrong i'm not going to
apologize for not being raw
i suppose you have a point
this has been dr ben carson contemplates
endorsing donald trump
this is breaking news on louder with
crowler i'm perry malassan we take you
now to a republican party currently
underway
boy what a night i really uh i really
tuckered myself out yeah yeah
so um do you do you need a lift you need
us to call you a cab oh no i got my own
car i can get home just fine okay well
yeah we're just
picking up here there's not a lot left
yeah you know i'd offer to help but with
the ibs you know hey does anyone want to
play a game of jenga why are you still
here we'll keep you updated as the
republican party progresses after this
um
all right i'm glad i was going to try
and throw a knife at jared in the studio
and i couldn't find my knife darn it not
gay jared you got the better of me
that's the first you couldn't find it it
hurt last time all right go do your work
to find a tweet if you haven't found it
yet all right i will do that okay so
we're going to wrap this program up
we're going to have rockiness tweet of
the show which you can send to me at s
crowder on twitter of course
lotterwithcredit.com is where you can go
for the podcast archives or the video if
you're listening to rest really
man it has been a a busy week and
um
i i
i don't know if i'm the only one who's
just exhausted with the process
i think a lot of people are with the
election process right now
the fact that the last debate scandal
was outpacing gop debate i think should
tell you something don't be too far into
the forest to see the trees okay
don't overestimate the influence of the
gop primary right now most people don't
really care
most people aren't paying attention as a
matter of fact that's why donald trump i
think is doing so well most people don't
really pay that much attention to
primaries unless they're political
hobbyists and donald trump is is a guy
who's had a reality show for years so
he's already a pop culture icon
so of course he's going to get a lot of
press coverage especially someone who's
polarizing but that's that's that's an
anomaly he's an outlier out
outside of that exception most people
don't pay that much attention and i
think a lot of conservatives out there
and a lot of a lot of leftists a lot of
people who are canvassing for bernie
activists
they develop an out-of-touchedness by
not being aware as to the level of
engagement for the average american
because it's not that high it really
isn't that high and that's why we
generate a lot of the content that we do
at the website which
you know listen it's not national review
it's not going to be policy wonky i mean
we did this rebuttal for vox.com with
over 30 sources i think that have been
used but it is important i think to to
realize that some people aren't engaged
there need to be several
several uh steps to that ladder and you
need to provide the first one as well so
that's what we try and do and and
hopefully maybe this election i think
donald trump could provide some value
there where some people who maybe
haven't been engaged at least have
perked up
and said oh i want to pay attention to
this and maybe it's through being
offended and they listen to what he has
to say and they're not all that offended
um i think bernie sanders has done that
a lot too i don't like what he says i
think a lot of people perk up because
they hear free stuff
and
um i think
then people can evolve and then you can
talk to them about policies and ideas
that's how it progresses that how that's
how it works listen if you also want to
talk about how to get young people on
board a lot of conservatives oh we got
the young vote you know because they're
they they're they're median demo and a
lot of conservative media is 72.
um you appeal to their selfish motives
or libertarian modes a lot of people my
age a lot of people not gay jared's age
they love the free stuff until they
realize that at some point they're going
to be hit with a tab
and when they realize that that's passed
down to them social security is a good
example if you can educate them on that
they can change their tune but if you
don't if you just tell them they're
stupid if you just tell millennials that
they're that they're lazy and they're
greedy and they suck all of which are
true mind you but that's the only thing
you say
you don't really win the argument just
like if you call everybody a liar in the
primary if every single person if you're
a ted cruz supporter and you call trump
rubio kasich christie
you called every single person a liar
and ted cruz is the candidate well guess
what when you call hillary clinton a
liar they're just going to say yeah but
you called everybody else a liar same
thing with donald trump if you call
everyone else a liar and you get to that
general and he goes hillary clinton's a
liar there's oh yeah you say everyone's
a liar it doesn't work anymore
so be um
be prudent
in the arguments that you present it is
time as we wrap up the show to go to
a place called vote and it's from
northern michigan and those who don't
know the story this is actually a tug
because depending on where i wear it my
down to it but well you know what the
truth
talk about how much
trump is okay
but we don't know that you can't
substantiate that obviously megan kelly
was calling breitbart trump bart and
several people have and and um
where we line up on that but uh
yeah i don't like john kasich i don't
like him at all but
you don't want to beat him with a lie
saying that soros is his pal uh maybe he
didn't maybe maybe i've missed something
but i have the article up from daily
caller and it was a certain amount from
an associate who's been a longtime
republican donor i probably don't like
this guy who's a longtime republican
donor my guess is he probably gave to
people like mccain and people like
mcconnell and he would probably be more
establishment but listen if you want to
beat someone don't just beat them on a
lie okay
leftists do that and i know some
conservatives say it's time to just do
that you know you can i can understand
the justification it's not something i
want to do so
learn that words matter that truth
matters learn how to to establish
meanings you know if someone throws out
an umbrella term right away if someone
says something and you go what does that
mean if someone says establishment or if
someone says mass shooting and that
doesn't doesn't define it if someone
just says oh patriarchy if ever in your
head you're thinking what does that mean
a lot of the time we're shy we're quiet
because we're afraid of sounding stupid
it's actually less stupid to just say
what do you mean by that
can you define what you mean by
patriarchy
can you define establishment for me
you won't sound stupid sure will be
stupid so ask questions define the words
louder with crowder we'll see you next
week